OKEY DOKE. THIS CALL THE MEETING
TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
WELCOME EVERYONE THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US LOOKING FOR TO
PRODUCTIVE HEARING- THIS MANY
WILL SEEK TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS
OF ALL WHO PARTICIPATE IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS FOR THE
WEEKEND. HAVE AFFECTED THE AND
DISCUSSIONS AND DECISIONS ON THE
CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA IN ORDER FACILITATE
THESE GOALS WILL NOT PERMIT
CONDUCT STRIPS DISTURB THE WISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS
PROCEEDINGS. AT THE END OF THE
HEARING WILL HAVE TIME FOR
LIMITED PUBLIC COMMENT MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC CAMPER TO SPEND IN
TODAY'S HEARING BY CALLING. IN
CALLING IN NUMBER.
1-877-692-8950 SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE ONE TWO SIX. YOU CAN ALSO
SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY BY
VISITING THE COMPANY'S WEBSITE
AT W. W. W. DOT A. E. M. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT C. A. DOT GOV.
PLEASE NOTE THAT ANY WRITTEN
TESTIMONY SUBMITTED. TO THE
COMMITTEE IT'S CONSIDER PUBLIC
COMMENT AND MAY BE READ INTO THE
RECORD OR REPRINTED. IN THE
NEARLY TWO AND A HALF YEARS
SINCE COVER NINETEEN ARRIVED INOUR STATE NEARLY EVERY ASPECT OF
OUR LIVES HAVE BEEN ALTERED. BUT
WHAT HASN'T CHANGED IS THAT
CALIFORNIA START THE FOREFRONT
OF THIS FIGHT WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE THE NATION'S MOST
INNOVATIVE RESPONSES BY ALWAYS
LISTENING TO SCIENCE. AND AS
MORE INFORMATION BECOMES
AVAILABLE ADAPTING OUR PLANS.
AFTER SUCCESSFULLY REOPENING THE
CON ME UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PANDEMIC ROAD MAP AND BLUEPRINT
FOR A SAFER ECONOMY THE SMARTER
PLANT IS THE LATEST ADAPTATION
OF CALIFORNIA'S RESPONSE PLANS.
THE SMARTER PLAN WAS RELEASED IN
FEBRUARY AS THE OMICRON VIRANT
SEARCH ENDED AND GOVERNOR NEWSOM
RESCINDED MOST OF COVER
NINETEENTH EXACT OF ORDERS. THE
SMARTER PLANT IS A NOBLE FIRST
IN THE NATION SHIFT AS IT GUIDES
CALIFORNIA'S EVOLVING RESPONSE
WITH A FOCUS ON CONTINUE READING
US AWARENESS. FLEXIBILITY AND
EQUITY. ADDITIONALLY THIS IS THE
FIRST PLAN DOESN'T AFTER BOTH
COPA NINETEEN AND ALL FUTURE
INFECTIOUS DISEASE EMERGENCIES.
AS CALIFORNIA IS NOW SEEN
ANOTHER RISING KOBE NINETEEN
CASES THE SMARTER PLAN FACES ITS
FIRST MAJOR TEST. I AM CONFIDENT
CALIFORNIA ONCE AGAIN RISE TO
THE OCCASION. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO VIE
WITH THIS WATER PLANT FOR THE
SAFETY OF THE ENTIRE STATE I
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM OUR
PANELISTS. ON THE STATUS OF THE
SMARTEST PLAN LOCAL AND
STATEWIDE IMPLEMENTATION. HOW
THIS WATER PLANT IS RESPONDING
TO THE RISING COVINA CASES AND
HOW THE LEGISLATURE CAN SUPPORT
THE SMART PLAN IN THE YEARS TO
COME. I WITHOUT IS THERE ANY
MEMBERS THAT WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
AN COMMENTS FRAZIER. OKAY ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO THERE FOR PANEL.
AS REMARKABLE HOLD QUITE UNTIL
THE END OF THE BROUGH OUR
PRESENTATION. FIRST PANEL FIRST
WE'LL HEAR FROM DR. MUNTU DAVIS
COUNTY HEALTH OFFICER OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH- DOCTOR DAVIS ARE
EITHER.
G. WIRELESSLY. DR DAVIS. I'M
HERE CAN YOU HEAR ME GO AHEAD
YOU'RE READY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
AND GOOD MORNING TO EVERYONE-
I'M DOCUMENTS YOU DAVIS THE L.
A. COUNTY HEALTH OFFICER I WANT
TO THANK YOU- COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
THREE GUESTS ON OUR WILL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY ABOUT OUR EXPERIENCE IN
TERMS OF IMPLEMENTING THE
SMARTER PLAN AND LA COUNTY'S
CULVER NINETEEN RESPONSE- AS
MANY OF YOU MAY KNOW L. A.
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH WORKS
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE STATE
THROUGH VARIOUS- ARE. IMPORTANT
FACETS OF OCTOBER NINETEEN
RESPONSE. OKAY OF THE SMARTER.
AND TODAY I'D LIKE TO SOME OF
THE KEY ACCOMPLISHMENTS WE
REACHED THAT DIRECTLY ALIGNED
WITH THE STATE'S SMARTER PLANT
AND SOME OF THE FORESEEABLE
CHALLENGES WE FACE GIVEN THE
CONTINUED COVERED NINETEEN
RESPONSE. TIME SO TO BEGIN AS OF
MAY EIGHTH R. EIGHTEEN MILLION
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND AND SIX HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX COVERED NINETEEN
VACCINE DOSES HAVE BEEN
ADMINISTERED IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. CURRENTLY 76% OF LA
COUNTY'S ELIGIBLE POPULATION
AGES FIVE YEARS AND OLDER IS
FULLY VACCINATED ABOUT 40% OF
THIS POPULATION HAS RECEIVED AT
LEAST ONE ADDITIONAL DOSES
WHILE. THESE RESULTS HAVE BEEN
MADE POSSIBLE THROUGH A ROBUST
NETWORK OF A VACCINE PROVIDERS-
THE COUNTY ITSELF STOOD UP A
ROBUST DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM FOR
VACCINES AND THERAPEUTICS WITH
SUPPORT FROM THE STATE AND THE
SYSTEM INCORPORATED THAT
SPECIALIZE HANDLING STORAGE AND
TECHNICAL SUPPORT NEEDS OF THE
VARIOUS VACCINE PRODUCTS AND
FOCUSES ON COMMUNITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY. BURDENED BY
OCTOBER NINETEEN. AS OF MAY
SEVENTH- THERE ARE NEARLY TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTY VACCINATION
SITES AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT LA
COUNTY WITH A PARTICULAR FOCUS
ON MAKING VACCINES READILY
AVAILABLE AND H. P. I. PLUS
COMMUNITIES. WE ALSO HAVE BEEN
WORKING TO DECREASE BARRIERS TO
VACCINE VARIABILITY FOR
RESIDENTS AND WORKERS ARE AND
THAT'S BEEN KEY PRIORITY FOR US
IN L. A. COUNTY. AND IT'S
REQUIRED UTILIZING VARIOUS TYPES
OF VACCINATION LOCATIONS
INCLUDING FIXED SITES SCHOOL
SITES AND MOBILE SITES. OF THE
TWO THOUSAND THAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER. ABOUT ONE THOUSAND AND
TWO HUNDRED OF THOSE ARE FIXED
SITES TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
OUR SCHOOL SITES AND FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO OUR MOBILE
SITES. ARE WE CURRENTLY PARTNER
WITH SIX- EXTERNAL MOBILE
PROVIDERS TO REACH HOME BOUND
RESIDENTS WHO ARE AT ELEVATED
RISK OF SEVERE ILLNESS. I'M NOT
ABLE TO TRAVEL TO THEIR SITE
BETTER- TO A VACCINATION SITES-
AND AS OF MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO THIS THIS YEAR. NEARLY TEN
THOUSAND RESIDENTS CONSIDERED
HOME BOUND OR VACCINATED. IN
TERMS OF THINKING ABOUT- BE
VACCINATED ALL FIFTY EIGHT
CAMPAIGN. YOU KNOW WE HAVE
COLLABORATED WITH THE TEAM AT
THE STATE'S ROMOTE VACCINATION
SITES AND BRING SUPPLEMENTAL
SERVICES AND INCENTIVES TO
VACCINATION SITES AND SOME OF
OUR HARDEST HARDEST TO REACH
COMMUNITIES. AND DESPITE THE
WORK WITH THE STATE SET TO STAND
UP SUPPORT AND PROMOTE THE
VARIOUS VACCINATION SITES
ATTENDED EFFORTS ARE STILL
IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS THE
DISPARITIES IN VACCINE UPTAKE.
CURRENTLY ONLY 32% OF ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN FIVE TO ELEVEN ARE
FULLY VACCINATED SIGNALING THE
NEED FOR ONGOING ACTIVITIES TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS BY PARENTS
STILL HAVE ABOUT VACCINE SAFETY
AND EFFECTIVENESS. BUT WHEN
LOOKING AT DATA BY RACE
ETHNICITY- 74% OF WHITE
RESIDENTS ARE FULLY VACCINATED
ABOUT FIFTY ALMOST 60% OF THAT
MATCH RESIDENTS ARE FULLY
VACCINATED. SIX POINT THREE A
BLACK AFRICAN AMERICAN RESIDENTS
ARE FULLY VACCINATED- ARE
CONCENTRATED ARE CONTRACTED A
COMMUNITY WORKERS- HAVE LET US
KNOW THAT THE RELAXING OF
INFECTION CONTROL REQUIREMENTS
MEANING MASKING OUR VACCINE
VERIFICATION NEWS OF WANING
VACCINE IMMUNITY AND INCREASED
LIKELIHOOD OF INFECTION WITH NEW
VARIANTS DESPITE BEING
VACCINATED BOOSTED BY HAVE ALL
DECREASED RESIDENTS PERCEPTION.
THE NINETEEN AS A CONTINUOUS
THREAT AND THAT VACCINATION AND
OTHER INFECTION CONTROL
MEASURES- REMAIN IMPORTANT-
ADDITIONALLY I L. A. COUNTY
MEDICAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
RESOURCES COORDINATED WITH THE
STATE MEDICAL HELP OPERATIONAL
AREA COORDINATION SYSTEM. TO
DEPLOY A NATIONAL AND STATE
GUARD- LOCALLY. TO STAFF SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AND ISOLATION
AND QUARANTINE OUR HOUSING SITES
AND TO RECEIVE AND DISTRIBUTE-
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
COVER NINETEEN ENGINE FAST AND
OTHER SUPPLIES. AND THESE ASSETS
HAVE ALLOWED US TO SUPPORT SNAPS
AND COLD JEAN MITIGATION TESTING
AND VACCINATION AS WELL AS
SUPPORTING PROVIDERS AND OTHER-
RESPONDING ENTITIES. I WITH THE
NEEDED SUPPLIES TO ENSURE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH IS PROTECTED. HOW
WE WORK AT THE STATE TO GET THE
WORD OUT ABOUT ADDITIONAL FREE
TEST KITS THAT CAN BE ORDERED.
DIRECTLY FROM CITY PAGES WHILE.
I'M AWARENESS READINESS- THIS
PLAN OUR LOCAL- OF ENSURING THAT
WE'RE MANAGING THE PANDEMIC WITH
ALL THE TOOLS AND RESOURCES AT
OUR DISPOSAL. AND AS A KEY
PRINCIPLE- IN TERMS OF EQUITY
NOT DATA THAT REFLECTS COMMUNITY
INFORMATION. BELONGS TO THE
PEOPLE AND SHOULD BE MADE
READILY AVAILABLE AND EASILY-
TIME EASY TO UNDERSTAND AND USE.
ANTHROPIC PANDEMIC WE HAVE. A
DATA ORGANIZED ORGANIZED IN
DIFFERENT WAYS READILY AVAILABLE
TO THE PUBLIC- AND PARTNERS.
UNDERSTAFFED WARDS HAVE BEEN
DEPLOYED AT THE HIGHLIGHT
PROGRESS AND ONGOING EFFORTS. IN
AREAS INCLUDING FROM THE
NINETEEN OUTCOMES VACCINE
ADMINISTRATION. I WOULD NINETEEN
TESTING CONTACT TRACING
OUTBREAKS OF BUSINESSES SCHOOLS
AND SCHOOL NURSING FACILITIES.
AND NOW OUR LOCAL EARLY ALERT
INDICATORS. I'M L. A. COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH NOW HASN'T.
DASHBOARD ON ITS WEBSITE- THAT
INCLUDES A LIST OF METRICS BUT I
SERVICE EARLY ALERT SIGNAL- FOR
AFTER PARIS MEASURES. AND WE
CONTINUALLY UPDATE THOSE- AS WE. SEE PROGRESS BEING MADE. I'M
IF ANY OF KEY WIDER SECTORS IN
THE TRIGGER I WILL BE CONCERN.
WE CAN SET WAYS AND PROTECTOR
STRATEGY- THE TOLL WE HAVE AN
SINCE STEPS RESIDENTS AND
WORKERS CAN TAKE. IN TO PROTECT
HOMES AND OTHERS- IN ADDITION WE
RECOMMEND ENSURING SUFFICIENT
FUNDING FOR- GENETIC SEQUENCING.
OF THOSE POSITIVE TEST THAT THAT
ARE IDENTIFIED. IN THIS SUPPORTS
OUR EFFORTS LOCALLY- ROUTINE
SEQUENCING A POSITIVE SPECIMENS
AS A KEY SURVEILLANCE METHODS.
BY WHICH ALLOWS US TO IDENTIFY
VARIANTS AND LINEAGES THAT MIGHT
HAVE SIGNIFICANT HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC. I WANT TO BE PROVIDE
OUR- PROOF HEALTH TO OUR- SINCE
THE SPREADABLE NINETEEN IS NOT
SIMPLY. TO ONE GEOGRAPHIC AREA
AS INDIVIDUALS COULD POTENTIALLY
TRAVEL BETWEEN AREAS WITH HIGHER
COVER NINETEEN TRANSMISSIONS
AREAS OF LOWER TRANSMISSION AND
VICE VERSA. I WILL ENSURE THAT
WE ALL CAN MAINTAIN OUR
SURVEILLANCE CAPACITY ACROSS THE
STATE. BUDGET CREATES THAT
AWARENESS THAT WE ALL NEED IN
ORDER TO RESPOND EFFECTIVELY- IN
TERMS OF THERAPEUTICS. CONTESTED
STREET. SOME OF THE VACCINATION
EFFORTS- OUR COLLABORATION WITH
THE STATE HAS ESTABLISHED A VAST
NETWORK OF MORE THAN EIGHT
HUNDRED PROVIDERS AND PHARMACIES
THROUGHOUT LA COUNTY. THAT ARE
PRESCRIBING OR DISPENSING
THERAPEUTICS. AND WE'VE BEEN
ENCOURAGING THE PUBLIC TO
CONTACT THEIR PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDER TO SEE IF THEY CAN
PROVIDE THE MEDICATIONS OR
PRESCRIPTION IF THEY HAVE. MILD
RAMADA ILLNESS. COMMITMENTS
SYMPTOMS I'M WE'VE ALSO BEEN
PROMOTING THE USE OF THE PROGRAM
- THE SITE FOR A AS YOU KNOW
SAME DAY TESTING AND THREE
THERAPEUTIC NOT SELECT
PHARMACIES COUNTY WIDE- AND IF
YOU'VE ALREADY BEEN TESTED YOU
CAN ALSO BRING YOUR POSITIVE
TEST OF THE SITE TO RECEIVE THE
MEDICATION. IF THE ONSITE
PROVIDER RECOMMENDS AND
PRESCRIBES IT- AND FINALLY WE'VE
BEEN PROMOTING FREE COGINT
NINETEEN MEDICATION TELEHEALTH
SERVICES. TO HELP RESIDENTS
DETERMINE WHETHER THEY MAY BE
ELIGIBLE FOR FREE COVER NINETEEN
THERAPEUTICS. AND CONNECT THEM
WITH THE RESOURCES FOR GETTING
TESTED DIAGNOSED AND A PRESCRIBE
THE APPROPRIATE MEDICINES. ARE
IN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH TELEHEALTH
PROVIDERS ARE AVAILABLE SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK TO SCREEN PATIENTS
FOR ELIGIBILITY. AND INDEPENDENT
ANYWAY- SPEAK ARAMBULA BIT MORE
ABOUT THE EDUCATION- IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY SCHOOLS
BEGAN RE OPENING IN PERSON
SERVICES. AND COUNTY AND USING
COUNTY AND STATE- GUIDANCE- AND
MOST ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS HAVE
REOPENED FOR IN PERSON LEARNING
. YOU KNOW IN FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- AND IN PREPARATION
PUBLIC HEALTH HOSTED REGULAR
MEETINGS WITH SUPERINTENDENTS
LABOR UNIONS AND PARENTS TO
DEVELOP. ANY SAFETY MATTERS ARE
CORPORATE SAFETY MEASURES AND
ADDRESS CONCERNS THAT THEY MAY
HAVE. UPDATING OUR GUIDANCE TO
REFLECT THE CHANGING CONDITIONS
AS WELL. WE'VE ALSO ESTABLISHED-
WHAT'S NOTED AS A SCOOL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TEAM OUR
STAFF TEAM. REASSIGNING SEVENTY
STAFFERS AND SCHOOLS NEWLY RE
OPENED- AND FOR ONGOING
OPERATIONS TO ENSURE SAFETY
MEASURES ARE BEING FOLLOWED AND
UNDERSTOOD. I AM OUT OF THE OVER
A THREE THOUSAND SCHOOLS IN L.
A. COUNTY BY JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE TEAM THAT COMPLETED A
TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDREDAND
SIXTY SCHOOL SITE VISITS- WE
ALSO ESTABLISHED- AND EXPOSURE
AND OPERATE MANAGEMENT TEAM-
THAT WORK WITH SCHOOLS. TO STOP
IN SCHOOL TRANSMISSION WHEN
CASES AND OUTBREAKS WERE
IDENTIFIED AND QUICKLY
THEREAFTER. OUTBREAKS. WERE
LIMITED TO A FEW THOUSAND. I'M I
THINK- ARE IN CLOSE- WE
APPRECIATE THE BEEN. AND
LEGISLATURE STRONG COMMITMENT TO
SUPPORT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WITH
ONGOING COMMITMENT OF TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PUBLIC HALTH INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND A CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP ARE
FOR OCTOBER NINETEEN RESPONSE.
NOW THIS LEVEL LONGER RESPONSE
CANNOT BE SUSTAINED A LOAN ON
LOCAL RESOURCES. AND IT WILL BE
CRUCIAL OR CRITICAL BACK FROM
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
HAVE THE RESOURCES AND SUPPORT
FOR OUR CURRENT AND POST
EMERGENCY COVERED NINETEEN. OUR
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY ACTIVITIES
WELL FOR EXAMPLE VACCINATION
TESTING AND COMMUNITY OUTREACH.
CONDUCTED BY TRUSTED PARTNERS. I
AND OTHER CORE PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICES- AND OUR COMMUNITY
SERVICE SUPPORT AS WELL. WE
THANK OUR STATE PARTNERS FOR
THEIR CONTINUED SUPPORT AND
COLLABORATION AND GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE A LOCAL PERSPECTIVE. AND
EXPERIENCE WITH EACH OF YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU A DOG DAVIS
ANNETTE AND HEAR FROM DANIEL
BOWERS DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
EMERGING MANAGEMENT THE CITY
SACRAMENTO. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR HAVING ME TODAY'S A
GREAT TO SEE YOU AGAIN AND MEET-
MEET THE OTHERS SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE. THAT JENSEN NEED TO
PRESENT WHAT THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO DOING ONGOING IN IN
DURING WE'RE HOLDING
NEIGHBORHOOD VACCINE CLINICS-
THE PELL CENTER- DOWN SOUTH
SACRAMENTO JUST USES A QUICK
EXAMPLE WE'RE BRINGING IN NEARLY
A DOZEN INTERPRETERS. AND
UTILIZING COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO GET THE WORD
OUT THROUGH THOSE COMMUNITIES TO
GET ACCESS TO A LOT OF OUR
ELDERLY FOLKS WITH VULNERABLE
UNDERLYING MEDICAL NATIONS WHO
ARE MOST SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE- TO
THE VIRUS. I TO GET THEM AND
INFORMED OF IT A LOT OF THE
OLDER COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND SOME
OF THOSE AREAS DO NOT SPEAK
ENGLISH AND SO WE'RE MAKING SURE
THAT WE WILL ROUTE THROUGH THOSE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
FOR BOTH- LINK. I THAT IS BEING
ACTIVE SO FAR WE'VE HAD VERY
GOOD TURN OUT OF THOSE IN THOSE
ARE ONGOING. WE'VE BEEN HOLDING
THOSE FOR- WELL OVER A YEAR NOW
AND- WE'VE SEEN. PRETTY STEADY
ATTENDANCE THAT'S PRETTY MUCH
INGRAINED ACROSS THE CITY WE
ALSO HAVE SOME OTHERS ROTATING
SITES THAT WE PARTNER WITH
SACRAMENTO COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
FOR AS WELL- IN IN FAIRLY GOOD
TURN OUT- WE HAVE DEACTIVATED.
OUR MOBILE VACCINE SITES THROUGH
SACRAMENTO FIRE JUST GIVEN THAT
THEIR- THE THAT DEMAND REALLY-
FELL OFF. SO WITH THAT AND I
ANTICIPATE AS ADDITIONAL BOOSTER
SHOTS COME OUT WILL CONTINUE
THOSE EFFORTS ACROSS THE-
COMMUNITY. ONE THING I CAN SAY
THAT- IT HAS BEEN VERY GOOD
WE'VE SEEN AN UPTICK IN TRUST.
COMMUNITY WITH. I THINK MORE
COMMONSENSE COMMUNICATION TO ON
THAT IF THEY ARE NOT
EXPERIENCING SYMPTOMS OR JUST
WATER SYMPTOMS TO STAY HOME.
DON'T OVER ONE THE HOSPITALS I
THINK WE'RE SEEING THOSE DIRECT
EFFECTS ACROSS THE COUNTY BY NOT
OVERWHELMING HOSPITALS AS WE IN
DURING THIS MOST RECENT WAVE. IT
SEEING THAT HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE
STAYING VERY LOW AMOUNTED TO
MONITOR THOSE VERY FREQUENTLY
AND WE'RE NOT SEEING THE UPTICK
THAT WE SAW DURING THE INITIAL
OMICRON VERY COMING OUT. IT'S
ALMOST AS A SLOW WAVE THAT WE'RE
SEEING HERE I THINK A LOT OF
THAT HAS TO DO WITH ADDITIONAL
COMMUNICATION AND BUILDING TRUST
IN THE PUBLIC AS- WITH OUR
FOCUSED EFFORTS. I NEXT JUST TO
SPEAK ABOUT TESTING WE'VE I
RECEIVE SEVERAL TESTS FROM OUR
SOCK MONKEY PUBLIC HEALTH
PARTNERS- THEY HAVE BEEN
EXCEPTIONAL WITH THAT WITH
PROVIDING THOSE REACHED. DEPLOY
THOSE TO OUR AGENCIES SO THAT IS
TO. HAVE A STAFF MEMBER ONE OF
OUR SOCIAL SERVICE WORKERS TEST
POSITIVE THE ENTIRE SECTION IS
TESTED IMMEDIATELY THAT WAY IT
MITIGATES ANY SORT OF
DISRUPTION. TO THAT ESSENTIAL
SERVICES A WHOLE WE'VE SEEN THAT
PRETTY EFFECTIVE WITH OUR FIELD
SERVICES- WE JUST ENDURED ONE OF
THOSE THIS WEEK. AND THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO CATCH THAT PRETTY
QUICKLY YOU KNOW ISOLATE THE
FOLKS WHO DO TEST POSITIVE- IN
SO THEY CAN GO HOME AND- AND-
YOU. DEAL WITH THOSE SYMPTOMS
UNTIL THEY FEEL BETTER- WITHOUT
DISRUPTING THE ENTIRE SECTION.
OUR POLICE AND FIRE DO THE SAME
THING WITH OUR NINE ONE DISPATCH
CENTERS WE KEEP AMPLE AMOUNT OF
TESTS RIGHT THERE TO ISOLATE ANY
SORT POTENTIAL OUTBREAK. WE HAVE
SEEN PRETTY EFFECTIVE- USE OUR-
OKAY OUR WORKFORCE. NOTABLY WITH
THAT IS SOMEBODY DOES FEEL SICK
THEY JUST SIMPLY DON'T GO IN
THAT DAY AND THEY HAVE THEIR
LAPTOP AND THEY HAVE THEIR THEIR
HOME WORKSTATION THAT THEY'RE
ABLE TO CONTINUE. DOING THE WORK
WE HAVEN'T SEEN A LOT OF SICK
PANDEMIC WITH THE USE OF THIS
HYBRID MODEL. FOLKS JUST
CONTINUE OPERATING AT HOME MAYBE
POTENTIALLY EXPERIENCING MILD
SYMPTOMS BUT THERE'S NO
DISRUPTION TO OPERATIONS AND SO
THAT'S BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE WE DO
PLAN TO KEEP THE HYBRID MODEL IN
PLACE. IN DURING I DON'T THINK
THAT'LL EVER CHANGE. AND IS LONG
AS THE WORK'S GETTING DONE IN
OUR OFFICE CENTRAL SERVICES AND
IN OUR ECONOMY OF OPERATIONS IS
NOT IMPACTED. WE'LL JUST MOVE
FORWARD WITH THAT IN THE- IN IN
IN. PRETTY MUCH A PERMANENT
POSTURE. A SPECIFIC TO P. P.
EARLY ON THE PANDEMIC WE WENT
INTO THIS- EVENT. WITH ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND N. NINETY FIVE
MASKS THAT THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO STARK THAT WAS A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT SACRAMENTO
FIRE. WE WERE NOT SELFISH WITH
THOSE MASKED WE WERE DEPLOYING
THOSE OUT WE GAVE THE HOSPITAL'S
FAR NORTH IS READING. GAVE OUT
TEN THOUSAND WERE TO THE VET- VA
HOSPITAL DOWN IT MAY THIRD. WE
SUPPLIED OTHER COUNTIES
JURISDICTIONS EVERY SINGLE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY AND FIRE
AGENCY. IN THIS REGION RECEIVE
MASKS IF THEY WANTED THEM- WE
KNEW AND UNDERSTOOD THAT THEY
NINETY FIVE IS THE BEST
PROTECTION WITH THAT. SINCE THEN
WITH GOOD PARTNERSHIP FROM THE
STATE WHICH WE'RE VERY THANKFUL
FOR THEY REPLENISH THOSE STOCKS.
WE NEVER GOT DEPLETED ALL THE
WAY DOWN- BUT WE DID WE DID HIT
LEVELS ABOUT FORTY FORTY FIVE
PERCENT. OF THAT. BUT AGAIN-
THAT WASN'T JUST USED TO BURN
RATE FROM THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO. THAT WAS DISBURSING
GOES OUT TO ALL OF OUR MUTUAL
AID PARTNERS IN ANYBODY WHO
WANTED THEM. THERE WAS NEVER
REQUEST THE CAME IN FOR AN IN
NINETY FIVE MASK FROM A- A
SENIOR LIVING FACILITY A
HOSPITAL ANY OF THOSE HEALTH
CARE. PARTNERS AND WERE DENIED
WE SUPPORTED EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THOSE REQUESTS AND CONTINUE TO
DO SO AS THEY COME IN- WE
PARTNER VERY CLOSELY WITH. THE
SENIOR LIVING FACILITIES EARLY
HONOR STANDING THAT THE ELDERLY
AND FOLKS WITH VULNERABLE
UNDERLYING MENTAL CONDITIONS.
WERE THE MOST AT RISK FOR THE
VIRUS. AT SEVERAL OF THOSE. HAVE
SINCE. YOU OTHERS. ROUTES BUT
EARLY ON WHEN THE PP WAS WAS
PRETTY LOW AND HARD TO COME BY
WE MAKE SURE THAT WE BACKSTOPS
THEIR SUPPLIES. THAT THEY HAD
SUFFICIENT AMOUNTS. I SINCE THEN
WE'VE REBUILT THOSE STOCKS AND
IN ARE READY FOR IT YOU KNOW
THEY NINETY FIVE COURSES- VERY
PROFICIENT AT. PROTECTING AS
WILDFIRE SMOKE PARTICULATES
WHICH WE'RE PROBABLY GOING TO BE
IN DURING HERE THIS SUMMER- IF
HISTORY IS ANY INICATION IN THE
IN THE CLIMATE IS HOW IT IS. SO-
WE ARE READY FOR THAT AND- IN
ANY SORT OF POTENTIAL. OUTBREAK
WE DO HAVE SUFFICIENT PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT ON HAND- TO
ENSURE THAT JUST AS WE WERE
BEFORE. AND THEN. I WILL CLOSE
OFF THAT I'VE BEEN SPEAKING
QUITE A BIT WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS EDUCATIONAL
LEADERS AND DOCTORS. WE ARE VERY
THANKFUL FROM A LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE TO THE STATE THAT WE
HAVE NOT REGRESSED IN
IMPLEMENTED ANY SORT OF
MANDATES. ESPECIALLY NOTABLE TO
THE TO THE CHILDREN. AND IN IN
THE SCHOOLS THAT HAS BEEN A HUGE
POINT OF CONTENTION FOR US. AT
THE SCHOOL BOARD MIESES SO
FORTH- NOW JUST SHARE WITH YOU
THAT ESSENTIAL SERVICE CHILD
CARE WORKER PROGRAMS WAS
IMPLEMENTED BY THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO EARLY ON THE
PANDEMIC. SO WHILE THE SCHOOL
SHUT DOWN. A LOT OF THOSE
STUDENTS JUST COULDN'T STAY AT
HOME THEY HAD PARENTS WHO WERE
FIREFIGHTERS POLICE OFFICERS
DOCTORS. WE COMMUNITY CENTERS.
HAVE CHILDREN GOING TO SCHOOLS
AND BEING TAUGHT BY EDUCATORS.
THEY WENT TO OUR COMMUNITY
CENTERS AND WERE WATCHED BY OUR
YOUTH PARKS AND REC. FOLKS I
MEAN THESE WERE THESE WERE NOT
SKILLED EDUCATORS BUT THEY DID
THEIR BEST- AND I JUST VERY
PROUD OF OUR FOLKS FOR.
BASICALLY OPENING UP PSEUDO
SCHOOLS. AND SO- FROM A LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE JUST VERY CANDIDLY I
DO WANT TO SAY. I DO APPRECIATE
AS WE IN DURING THESE ADDITIONAL
WAVES THAT YOU'RE NOT SHUTTING
DOWN THE SCHOOLS YOU'RE NOT
GETTING AGGRESSIVE WITH THE MASK
MANDATES. FOR CHILDREN- BECAUSE
WE ARE SEEING A- AND I'D SEE AN
INCREASE IN TRUST AND CONFIDENCE
BY OUR OUR LOCAL. BEAUTY THAT
WE'RE NOT DOING. ANY SO AGAIN
OUR PRIMARY FOCUS IF AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IS TO CONTINUE
FORTIFYING. THE SENIOR LIVING
FACILITIES. PARTNER WITH THE
HOSPITALS TO MAKE SURE THE MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS ARE
PROTECTED WHICH ARE ELDERLY AND
THOSE WITH UNDERLYING MEDICAL
CONDITIONS. AND THEN TO. PROVIDE
THAT THAT DURING SUPPORT TO OUR
EMPLOYEES AND PARTNER AGENCIES.
SO THEY ARE CENTRAL SERVICES DO
NOT GET DISRUPTED- WHEN FOLKS
AFTER YOU- CALL OUT. WHETHER
THEY'RE ILL OR OR SO FORTH SO.
YOUR QUESTIONS- JIM AND THAT
CONCLUDES MY BRIEF. WHAT THANK
YOU DINNER APPRECIATE YOUR INPUT
NOW LET'S- ARE NOT STUBBORN ON
THE FIRST PANEL IT'S A DOCTOR
AMY. SISK CAL HOW. THE YELLOW.
SERVICES AGENCY OUR DOCTOR ARE
YOU AVAILABLE. YEAH I AM CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN. OKAY GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
YOUR COUNTIES EXPERIENCE
TRANSITIONING TO THE NEXT OF OUR
COVERED NINETEEN RESPONSE. IN
MID FEBRUARY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RELEASED IT SMARTER
PLAN THE SMARTER PLAN PAINTS A
PICTURE OF WHAT THE NEXT PHASE
OF THE STATE CODE RESPONSE WILL
LOOK LIKE AND IT OUTLINES
ACTIONS THE STATE WILL TAKE. A
SMARTER PLAN OF THE STATE PLAN
RATHER THAN A LOCAL PLAN AND I
DON'T VIEW MY CHARGES YOU'LL
COUNTY HEALTH OFFICER AS BEING
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SMARTER
PLAN PER SE. WHILE THE SMARTER
PLAN DOESN'T OUTLINE SPECIFIC
ACTIONS TO BE TAKEN BY LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THE ACRONYM
SMARTER THAT FORMS THE BASIS OF
THE PLAN. STILL SERVES AS A
USEFUL FRAMEWORK FOR YELLOW
COUNTY AS WE TRANSITION INTO THE
NEXT PHASE OF THE CURVE NINETEEN
RESPONSE. I'D LIKE TO BRIEFLY
REVIEW YOUR COUNTIES APPROACH TO
THE SEVEN FOCUS. OF THE SMARTER
PLAN. MATH AWARENESS READY TO
CASTING EDUCATION AND TREATMENT
OR R. ACTS. LET'S BEGIN WITH
SHOT VACCINES ARE THE MOST
POWERFUL WEAPON WE HAVE AGAINST
SEVERE DISEASE HOSPITALIZATION
AND DEATH FROM COVERT NINETEEN.
INYO COUNTY 74% OF RESIDENTS
FIVE AND OLDER HAVE COMPLETED A
PRIMARY THEORIES OF THE COMPANY
BAXEEN. OVER EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND
DOSES OF VACCINE HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED BY YOLO COUNTY ITSELF
AS A VACCINE PROVIDER SINCE
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY. WE
ENVISION A FUTURE IN WHICH THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM TAKES
OWNERSHIP OVER COVERT NINETEEN
VACCINATION MUCH LIKE IT DOES
FOR ANNUAL INFLUENZA VACCINATION
BUT WE'RE NOT THERE YET. AS MUCH
AS YOLO COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
WOULD LIKE TO- DEMOBILIZE THEIR
COVERT ACTION NATION TEAM AFTER
A YEAR AND A HALF OF CLINICS WE
EXPECT THAT PUBLIC HEALTH WILL
PLAY A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
VACCINATING CHILDREN UNDER FIVE
LIKELY BEGINNING NEXT MONTH. I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THE INCENTIVES OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IS OFFERING TO
PROVIDERS TO VACCINATE CHILDREN.
BUT HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
ENROLLMENT REMAINS WELL. THE
NEXT FOCUS AREA MATH IS ONE OF
THE MOST CHALLENGING. PROPERLY
WORN MASKS WITH GOOD FILTRATION
HELP FLOW THE SPREAD OF COVERT
NINETEENTH. WHEN THE STATE ENDED
ITS MASKING MANDATE IN MOST
INDOOR SETTINGS IN MARCH WE
TRANSITION TO STRONGLY
RECOMMENDING MASK. A STRONG
RECOMMENDATION WAS FRAMED AS
PART OF A CONTINUUM RANGING FROM
MATH OPTIONAL TO RECOMMENDED TO
STRONGLY RECOMMENDED AND
REQUIRED. HOWEVER NO DETAILS
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED AS TO WHEN
MOVEMENT BETWEEN THESE LEVELS
WILL OCCUR. THIS LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY UNDERMINES
CONFIDENCE IN PUBLIC HEALTH AT
THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL. THE
STATE HAS MAINTAINED A STRONG
RECOMMENDATION FOR MASKING SINCE
MARCH FIRST. IN MARCH AND TODAY
THE CASE READ IN YOLO COUNTY HAS
RANGED FROM FOUR TO TWENTY ONE
CASES PER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
RESIDENTS PER DAY REPRESENTING
MODERATE SUBSTANTIAL AND HIGH
COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION IN TURN.
OF A LOCAL HEALTH OFFICER MY
HANDS HAVE BEEN RELATIVELY TIED
BY THE STATE'S APPEARANCE TO A
STRONG RECOMMENDATION TO MASK
EVEN IF CASE RATES PLUNGED
LOCALLY. WHEN THE LOCAL CASE
RATE WAS FOUR I WOULD HAVE LIKED
TO MESSAGE THAT MASKING HAD
BECOME OPTIONAL BUT I WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN ALIGNED WITH STATE
MESSAGING. WHEN THE CASE RATE
BEGAN RISING I WOULD HAVE
STEPPED UP MY RECOMMENDATION
ACCORDING TO TRANSMISSION RISK.
INSTEAD I'VE BEEN SAYING ALL
ALONG THAT MASTER STRONGLY
RECOMMENDED AND PEOPLE HAVE
STOPPED LISTENING. IF WE WANT
HE PUBLIC TO HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
PUBLIC HEALTH MESSAGING WE MUST
BE MORE NIMBLE AND ARE MASKING
RECOMMENDATIONS ADJUSTING THEM
AS THE RISK OF JOSH. I
UNDERSTAND THE CDPH OF
DEVELOPING METRICS FOR WHEN TO
INCREASE MASKING RECOMMENDATIONS
I WENT TO DECREASE THEM AND I
VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO THE
RELEASE OF THIS MUCH NEEDED
FRAMEWORK. MOVING TO AWARENESS
THE SMARTER PLAN CALLS OUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF STAYING AWARE OF
HOW KOBE NINETEEN IS SPREADING
EVOLVING VARIANCE AND
COMMUNICATING CLEARLY HOW PEOPLE
SHOULD PROTECT THEMSELVES. THIS
LAST PIECE COMMUNICATING CLEARLY
IS AN AREA NEEDING ONGOING
ATTENTION AND INVESTMENTS. WE
HAVE OVER COMPLICATED MUCH OF
OUR CO THAT GUIDANCE AND ALSO
FAILED TO ADJUST THEM AS REF
CHANGED OVER TIME. I ENCOURAGE
INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC HEALTH
COMMUNICATION AS PART OF READY
TO WHICH I'LL RETURN TO IN A
MOMENT. INYO COUNTY WE'RE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE TREMENDOUS
VISIBILITY INTO CIRCULATING STAR
KOBE TO VARIOUS. IN REAL TIME
THE UC DAVIS GENOME CENTER
GENOTYPES EVERY POSITIVE TEST ON
THE UC DAVIS CAMPUS AND THROUGH
HEALTHY YELLOW TOGETHER LARGE
COMMUNITY TESTING PROGRAM. WHEN
MY COLLEAGUES IN OTHER COUNTIES
HAD ONLY SEEN DELAYED A WHOLE
GENOME SEQUENCING RESULTS FOR A
HANDFUL OF OMICRON CASES IN
JANUARY I WAS ABLE TO SAY THAT
ALL MICRON WAS ALREADY THE
DOMINANT VARIANT AND YELLOW
COUNTY WHICH ALLOWED OUR
PROVIDERS TO ADJUST THEIR
TREATMENTS ACCORDINGLY. NOW AS
UNREPORTED HOMES HAS BECOME MORE
POPULAR AND WE INCREASE RELIANCE
ON WASTE WATER SURVEILLANCE TO A
FAST COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION. I
AM GRATEFUL TO HAVE MULTIPLE
YOLO COUNTY WASTE SITES
MONITORED FREQUENTLY BY PARTNERS
AT UC DAVIS AND STANFORD AND I
HOPE SUCH NETWORKS CAN BE EXTENT
EXPANDED STATEWIDE. WITHIN THE
FOCUS AREA OF RIGHT ENOUGH WE
RECOGNIZE THAT KOBE NINETEEN.
BONTA COVERT SEARCHES AS WELL AS
FUTURE PANDEMICS. INYO COUNTY WE
ARE ANALYZING OUR RESPONSE TO
DATE IN ORDER TO BUILD ON
LESSONS LEARNED OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS. ONE LESSON IS ALREADY
VERY CLEAR WE DID NOT HAVE
ENOUGH TRAINED STAFF TO RESPOND
TO KOBE NINETEEN AND WE FELL
BEHIND IN OUR RESPONSE AS A
RESULT. I WAS PLEASED TO SEE
THAT THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH. BUT THIS
INVESTMENT IS NOT OFF TO PONDER
THE LONGSTANDING AROSE IN OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE. WE NEED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO INVEST IN
A PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE
PIPELINE ALONG WITH WORKFORCE
RETENTION. I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONSIDER FURTHER SUPPORTING AND
STRENGTHENING OUR CRITICAL LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE.
INITIATIVES SUCH AS THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EQUITY AND READY ENOUGH
OPPORTUNITY OR HERO WOULD HELP
ENSURE WE APPLY THE LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THE COBIT PANDEMIC
TO BE READY FOR THE NEXT
PANDEMIC. MOVING ON TO TESTING.
TESTING HELPS TO MINIMIZE THE
SPREAD OF COVERT NINETEEN. INYO
COUNTY WE HAVE BENEFITTED FROM
WIDELY AVAILABLE FROM BASED PCI
TESTING OFFERED BY HEALTHY
YOU'LL TOGETHER A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN UC DAVIS YOLO COUNTY AND
SO ANNUAL COUNTY AND IT HAD THE
HIGHEST PER CAPITA TESTING RATED
CALIFORNIA FROM MUCH OF THE
PANDEMIC- THIS TESTING. WILL ADD
ON JUNE THIRTIETH REPRESENTING A
MAJOR TRANSITION IN OUR COVERT
RESPONSE. WE ARE INVESTING IN A
TESTING FUTURE CENTERED ON HOLD
ANTIGEN TEST. DOCUMENTED BY
TESTING BY HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
AND PHARMACIES. WE ARE PREPARING
TO LAUNCH A VENDING MACHINE
PILOT PROGRAM THAT WILL
DISTRIBUTE FREE HOME ANTIGEN
TEST IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AND CONTINUE TO
MASTERS THE AVAILABILITY OF FREE
ANTIGEN TEST FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS WELL AS THROUGH
INSURANCE REIMBURSEMENT. YOUR
COUNTY REMAINS GRATEFUL TO CDPH
FOR ITS ONGOING SUPPORT OF AN
OPTUM SERVE TESTING LOCATION IN
YOUR COUNTY ALONG WITH OUTBREAK
TESTING SUPPORT PROVIDED BY
STATE OUTBREAK RESPONSE TEAMS
THAT HAVE SUPPORTED TESTING IN
OUR JAIL AND IN OUR SCHOOLS.
SPEAKING OF SCHOOL FOR THE FOCUS
AREA OF EDUCATION OUR SCHOOL
COATED RESPONSE HAS EVOLVED
SIGNIFICANTLY SINCE THE SMARTER
PLAN WAS REALLY. THE EMPLOYEE OF
GREW CONTACT TRACY IF OF INTO.
CALL TREE HUNDRED THE WERE FOR
SCHOOL STAFF WITHOUT. STUDENT
SAFETY. FOR THEN YOU'RE LOOKING
ARE A TO WHAT ROLE THEY WILL BE
A TO PLAY AND HAS DURING THE
NEXT ACADEMIC YEAR I THINK TO
RETURN THEIR TO TEACHING AND
AWAY FROM FACILITATING. WE HOPE
THAT OUR COMMUNITY EVENT MACHINE
. CAN AS A MODEL FOR HOW SCHOOLS
MIGHT BE ABLE TO DISTRIBUTE TEST
FIFTY AND FAMILIES WITH MINIMAL
STAFF WORK. FINALLY IN THE AREA
OF TREATMENT YOUR COUNTY OF
EXCITED THAT THE STATE SPONSORED
OPTUM SERVES FIGHT IN WOODLAND
IS NOW ATTACHED TO TREAT
LOCATION. PASSAGE BRING TEST A
PROVIDER VISIT AND PRESCRIPTION
FOR A THERAPEUTIC AND DISPENSING
OF THAT THERAPEUTIC UNDER ONE
ROOF MAKING IT EASY FOR THOSE AT
HIGH RISK OF SEVERE DISEASE TO
QUICKLY ACCESS. TREATMENTS LIKE
PARK SLOPE IT. HAVING OFTEN
SERVE AS A ONE STOP SHOP IS A
HUGE WIN BUT ITS IMPACT WILL
LIKELY BE NARROW. NOW WIDELY
AVAILABLE AND PHARMACIES HAVE
PLENTY OF TAX WILL BID BUT FOR
MOST PEOPLE WHO TEST POSITIVE
THE CHALLENGES AND HAVING A
PROVIDER GETTING INTO SEE THAT
PROVIDER WITHIN DAYS OF TESTING
POSITIVE AND HAVING THAT
PROVIDER BE COMFORTABLE
PRESCRIBING PACKED FULL OF IT. I
THAT IF WIDE. CAN BE DEVELOPED
OUTSIDE OF OFTEN SERVE TO
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL CALIFORNIANS
IN ACCESSING TREATMENT PROVIDERS
ALONG WITH PROVIDING INCENTIVES
FOR LARGE HEALTH SYSTEMS TO
IMPLEMENT TOUGH TO TREAT MODELS
. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY ABOUT YOLO COUNTY IS
INVOLVING KOBE NINETEEN. THANK
YOU DOCTOR AND WITH THAT OUR
BRINGING HERE TO THE MEMBERS BUT
IT SOUNDS LIKE- FROM FROM THE
THREE ON THE FIRST PANEL IS AT
THE COUNTER ARE NOT ALWAYS A LOT
BETTER TO DEAL WITH THAT- AS WE
DID IN THE BEGINNING OF THE
ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC AND THAT'S
WHY PART OF THE HEARING HERE TO
SEE HOW ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
ARE BETTER. TO PER TO RESPOND
TREAT AND HAVE- PLAN AND MOST
PROBABLY HAVE THE STOCKPILES OF
THE PP THINGS THAT WE NEED- IN A
BETTER PLACE SO IS THERE
ANYTHING ELSE YOU THINK WE CAN
LOOK AT- FROM ANYBODY THAT'S ON
THE FIRST PANEL I WE CAN DELIVER
BETTER. YOUR THINGS SEEM TO BE
FALLING INTO PLACE FOR ONE OF MY
MOTHER'S THAT DIFFERENT SEARCHES
THAT COM- IS THERE ANYTHING
BECAUSE OF THE DIFFERENT- US-
ARIENS. OF THE- DISEASE THAT
WOULD COME THAT WE NEED TO ADAPT
DIFFERENTLY OR I THINK SOME LIKE
EVERYTHING'S PRETTY GOOD ON THAT
AND BUT IF ANYBODY ELABORATE. A
WHAT IF WANT IN DOWN AFTER SIR
TO. KIND OF REINFORCE AGAIN TOO
I THINK THE COMMUNITY THAT YOU
KNOW MILD TO MODERATE SMPTOMS
DON'T GO TO THE HOSPITAL'S. AND-
YOU KNOW SELF TREAT- CONTACT-
YOU HELL CARE PROVIDER THAN ALL
- THEIR RECOMMEND. I THAT'S JUST
BEEN A HUGE WHEN I'VE- I KNOW IN
OUR OUR COUNTY SACRAMENTO COUNTY
THEY'VE BEEN ADVERTISING THAT.
THEY STARTED OUT OF A COUPLE
MONTHS AGO AND THE TRANSITION
HAS BEEN HAS BEEN HUGE I READ A
STUDY IN AND MY APOLOGIES I
CAN'T QUOTE WHO WAS FROM BUT- IT
WAS TAKEN BACK INTO BELIEVE IS
JANUARY- BUT IF THERE WAS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF THE
POPULATION THAT FELT STILL. EVEN
IN JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THAT IF YOU GOT C
ING TO PERISH AND WHICH I
THINK THROUGH BETTER EDUCATION
FROM PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
OVER THESE PAST COUPLE MONTHS.
THAT HAS- YOU KNOW THAT HELPED
INCREASE THE AWARENESS AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THE VIRUS-
WHILE WHILE IT CAN BE VERY
TRAGIC. THEY HAD TO. DO IT IT
IS. IT'S A SAID. WHERE IF YOU.
TEST POSITIVE AND YOU'RE A
SYMPTOMATIC THE NEED TO RUSH
DOWN TO A HOSPITAL DEMAND TO BE-
TO BE ADMITTED. TO IT AND THEN
THE OTHER THING IS JUST. SIMILAR
WHAT WE'RE DOING I FEEL A IN
OUR- IN OUR CITY. I DEPARTMENTS
IN ORGANIZATION PUSHING TESTS
MPPT DOWN TO THAT DEPARTMENT
LEVEL IF THERE'S A WAY TO JUST
MAKE SURE THAT THE SCHOOLS HAVE
THAT TESTING IN PP PUSHED DOWN
TO THEIR LEVEL AS WELL WITH THE
REINFORCED UNDERSTANDING THAT
WE'LL- THE CLOSING OF THE
SCHOOLS FOR DIFFERENT VARIANTS
IS JUST NOT GOING TO BE AN
ACCEPTABLE ROUTE FORWARD. AND
INDIO WHILE TEACHERS MAY FEEL
THE NEED TO HAVE ANY NINETY FIVE
THE HOBBIT READILY AVAILABLE-
AND I KNOW I'VE I SPOKE WITH MY
SAFETY AND SECURITY FOLKS FROM
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN MY IN MY
CITY AND I AYE REINFORCE DEMAND
THEIR FACILITIES STAFF THAT IF
THEY NEED ANY SUPPLIES. I'LL
HAVE THAT ON THEIR DOORSTEP THE
NEXT DAY- THAT WAY THEY
UNDERSTAND FULLY THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THE SCHOOLS NEED TO DO
UNLESS IT'S UNLESS IT'S A VERY
SIGNIFICANT- FUTURE PANDEMIC-
THAT IS MUCH MORE LETHAL NEED TO
KEEP SCHOOL OPEN OKAY. THANK YOU
- ANY QUESTION FROM VICE CHAIR
CERTAIN SO IT I THINK THE
FRAMEWORK- THAT HAS BEEN LATER
OUT THE SMARTER PLAN- I THINK
IT'S A GOOD FRAMEWORK FOR-
ADDRESSING COVERT GOING FORWARD
. I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
TO BE DONE STILL- BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF UNKNOWNS WE-
HAVE NO LONG TERM STUDIES. THAT
ARE IT GIVE US. ALL THE EXACT
ANSWERS THAT WE NEED AND SO WHAT
I THINK YOU HAVE A WILL FLUID IS
GONNA BE A- AS WE FORWARD. THE
BACK ISSUE I THINK IT'S MOVED
FROM AVAIL. WHICH WERE IMPACT
LARGELY TO NOW I THINK IT'S
READILY AVAILABLE EVERYWHERE ANY
OF THE- FROM THIS. IN OF THE
COUNTY'S ANY ISSUES THE VEIL OF
VACCINE. AND AT AND SITES WHERE
PEOPLE CAN GO GET VACCINATED
BECAUSE I DON'T SEE LONG LINES
ANYMORE I DON'T SEE ANY OF THAT
. ANYWAY ON THE FIRST PANEL- HOW
. CAN ADD THAT IF THERE'S ANY
ISSUES. HI THIS IS DOCTOR SUSAN
ANNUAL ACCOUNTING CAN SAY THAT
WE HAVE NO SHORTAGE OF A VACCINE
AND WE HAVE- AMPLE. PLACE
ALTHOUGH WE DO ANTICIPATE ON AS
I MENTIONED IN IN MY TESTIMONY A
SHORTAGE OF PROVIDERS WHO ARE
WILLING TO- PROVIDE VACCINES TO
THE UNDER FIVE AGE GROUP WICH
WE ANTICIPATE WILL BE AUTHORIZED
IN JUNE- AND I KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH HAS HAD AN INCENTIVE TO
RECRUIT- THE EXISTING VACCINE
PROVIDERS OF OTHER VACCINES TO
PROVIDE KOBE BACK IN ASIANS AND
SO THAT. THAT WORK IS ON BUT NO
YELLOW COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
INTENDS TO CAN GIVING
VACCINATIONS. TO THE UNDER FIVE
POPULATION- I IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE ADEQUATE ACCESS.
SO IT'S TO SAY THAT THE- PEOPLE
THAT WISH TO GET A VACCINE. HAVE
FULL ACCESS AND AVAILABILITY OF
THE VACCINE TO GO GET IF THEY
WISH CORRECT. AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL SUCH INTERESTING AND
COUNTY LEVELS SIR I CAN SAY-
THAT WE'VE BEEN RUNNING THESE
PUBLIC VACCINE CLINICS SINCE
EARLY SPRING LAST YEAR AND WE
HAVE NEVER TURNED A PERSON AWAY
EVEN AS OF LAST SPRING SO TO
YOUR RATE POINT YOUR SPOT ON
AND- WE'VE- ENGAGE LINGUIST. L.
A. FO TAKE REACH TO THOSE REALLY
TO REACH NEIGHBORHOODS THROUGH
CA BASED. FOR THE TRUST ASPECT
OF IT WE'VE NEVER TURN ANYBODY
AWAY- FROM A VACCINE. NEWS I
GUESS WHAT I'M GETTING AT ALSO
IS THAT AT SOME POINT WE'VE
SATURATED. THE VACCINATION.
OUTREACH AND ABILITY. AND IT'S
AVAILABLE TO THOSE THAT WANT TO
AND THOSE THAT DON'T ARE JUST
NOT GOING TO GET IT. ABSOLUTELY
AND TO OUT THE COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICER FOR WE'RE ALSO SEEING
THAT. TO SEVERAL OF PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS- MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
THEY ARE ALSO JUST NOT READY TO
DISTRIBUTE TO THAT TO THE YOUNG
CHILDREN UNDER UNDER FIVE OKAY
GREAT. WILL MOVE ON TO. LOCAL
COMMUNITY HOSPITALS- IN YOUR
DISTRICTS IN THE COUNTY AREAS.
DO THEY HAVE THE SAME PERCEPTION
OF HOW THIS IS WORKING AS- THE
YOUR COUNTY HEALTH OFFICES AND
WOULD YOU HAVE. THE
COMMUNICATION YOU NEED WITH
THEM- REGARDING PP AVAILABILITY-
SUPPLY CHAIN- ISSUES ANYTHING
LIKE THAT BECAUSE I KEEP HEARING
FROM WHEN I'M SPEAKING TO PEOPLE
IN THE PRE ARE IN THE HOUSE.
CARES THAT THERE WHEN YOU CAN TO
BE THE UP. THE PP WHEN WE HAVE
SURGES. SO IF YOU IF THE THREE
OF YOU MAY BE ABLE TO GIVE US
SOME INDICATION OF WHAT- WHERE
WE'RE AT- WITH THOSE
COMMUNICATIONS AND ADDRESSING
THE HOSPITAL. NEEDS SO THAT THEY
ARE WELL PREPARED AND THERE'S NO
SAP SUPPLY CHAIN- DISRUPTIONS-
WHEN WIND A SURGEON KERR'S. I
YES SIR OUR VERY CLOSELY WITH MY
HOSPITAL COORDINATORS AND FROM
THE EARLY ON THE PANDEMIC I
MENTIONED THAT- THE INITIAL- THE
INITIAL. FIRST WAS IN NINE FIVE
AND IT'S BECAUSE OF OUR WILDFIRE
PREPAREDNESS FOR THE SMOKE
ACROSS THE COMMUNITY WE HAD.
AMPLE AMOUNTS OF IN NINETY FIVE
AND WE DISTRIBUTE THOSE OUT WITH
THAT RELATIONSHIP BUILDING OF
PROVIDING THOSE IN NINETY FIVE-
MASS THROUGHOUT THE HOSPITAL
NETWORK WE DEVELOP GOOD.
ORDINATION AND COMMUNICATION I
HAVE NOT HEARD FROM MY HOSPITALS
IF THEY'RE THEY'RE SHORT ON THAT
I FEEL THAT THEY WOULD BE
CONFIDENT TO COME TO MYSELF OR
OUR- THE CITY. TO RECEIVE IN
NINETY FIVE IF THEY NEEDED IT- I
HAVEN'T HEARD AT LEAST IN
SACRAMENTO- YOU NEED OF CONCERN
ABOUT P. BUT- I DON'T WANT TO
SPEAK COMPLETELY FOR THE
HOSPITALS THEY MIGHT HAVE LIKE
YOU SAID SIR DEFERRED. YOUR
DURING- DURING DIFFERENT WAVES
THEY MIGHT HAVE SHORT SHORTER-
LIMIT ON PP BUT I HAVEN'T. HAD
ANY S. ANY ISSUES COME TO MY
ATTENTION. AND THE OTHERS. IN IN
YOUR COUNTY AYE MEET REGULARLY
WITH OUR HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP AND
I WOULD SAY FOR THE FIRST COUPLE
COBIT WAIVES THE CHALLENGE WITH
CERTAINLY AVAILABILITY OF PP. I
THINK NOW THAT SUPPLY CHAINS ARE
ARE FLOWING OUT PROPERLY AND OUR
MOLOCH PROGRAM IS ALSO AVAILABLE
AS SORT OF AS A AS A BACKUP IF.
A HOSPITAL IS NOT ABLE TO ACT OF
P. P. A. I WOULD SAY THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE THAT OUR HOSPITALS
EXPERIENCED AND IN THE LAST WAVE
AND WITH THIS CURRENT INCREASE
IN IN CASE IF THE SCARCITY. IS
IN STAFFING IS NOT IN PP- R.
MANY STAFF THEMSELVES HAVE BEEN
INFECTED WITH OVER NINETEEN AND
HAVE NOT BEEN AVAILABLE TO WORK
AND SO THAT IS THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE CURRENTLY FACING OUR
HOSPITALS. YEAH AND I THINK THAT
STAFFING ISSUES SOMETHING I'VE
HEARD OVER AND OVER AND- IT'S A
BIG ISSUE IN PART OF IT IS
FUELED BY- WELL BEING. AFRAID TO
GO INTO THAT FIELD ANYMORE. AND
SO WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT ENVIRONMENT IS AS SAFE. AS
WE CAN MAKE IT AND THEY HAVE THE
PP THEY NEED TO BE FEEL
CONFIDENT. THAT THEIR JOB CAN BE
DONE AND THAT THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO BE OVERWORKED. AND SO THAT'S
A THAT'S A HUGE ISSUE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- SO THE- THE DOCTOR.
JUST SAID YOU HAD BROUGHT UP THE
ISSUE OF LOCAL HEALTH ADVISORIES
VERSUS STATE ORDERS. AND THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT THE COUNTIES
NEED. TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THEIR COUNTY
. DO YOU FEEL THAT THAT AT
RESTRICTION GUYS ARE BEING
AFFORDED THAT. AND THAT'S KIND
OF WHAT I'M HEARING IS THAT THE
STATE IS STILL DOING THE DOING
THE MAIN ORDER AND THEN THAT
COUNTIES ARE STUCK TRYING TO
IMPLEMENT SOMETHING THAT'S NOT
REALLY SUITABLE FOR THEIR COUNTY
. IS CORRECT IS THAT DAY HERE
THAT RIGHT- IT'S A IT'S A
SLIGHTLY MORE NUANCED AND NOT
WHEN IT COMES TO THE MASKING
PIECE THE CHALLENGE HERE WAS WAS
NOT HAVING A STATE ORDER PER SE.
THAT WAS STRICTER THAN THE STATE
WE ARE TALKING RECOMMENDATION.
SO THERE IS NOT- DOES THE SAME
LEVEL OF OBLIGATION FOR A COUNTY
STILL TO FOLLOW ITS STATE
RECOMMENDATION AS THAT IS WHAT
THE STATE ORDER BUT I THINK THAT
THE CHALLENGES MORE ON
COMMUNICATION. AND ENSURING THAT
THERE IS A FRAMEWORK PLACE FOR
HOW WE CAN YOU. ABOUT MASKING
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT I WOULD SAY
IN IN GENERAL- MANY COUNTIES ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE STATE'S. TO
ISSUE STATE ORDERS BECAUSE IN
MANY CASES. THERE IS NOT THE
STEP. QUEUE IS THOSE THAT'LL
LEVEL. RIGHT THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT I WAS THINKING
ABOUT WHY YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
THAT IS- A LOT OF TIMES OF
SPECIAL SCHOOL BOARDS. THEY WANT
THEY WANT SOMEBODY ELSE TO GIVE
THOSE ORDERS SO THAT THEY CAN.
THEY CAN BE COMPLIANT AND- AND
BE ABLE TO TELL PEOPLE IT'S NOT
THERE. THEIR RESPONSIBILITY TO.
CREATE THAT- SO WE HAVE TO FIND
BALANCE SO YOU GUYS STILL HAVE
THAT FLEXIBILITY YOU NEED.
WITHOUT DOING THAT I'LL LET
OTHERS ASK QUESTIONS FIVE
EXHAUSTED A COUPLE DIFFERENT
THINGS. I FRANKLY. DON'T HAVE
FIRST WELL YOU TO OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH OF PEOPLE THE DONE SUCH
INCREDIBLE. I KNOW WE HAD SOME
ROUGH SPOTS IN THE BEGINNING
HOWEVER YOU'VE ALL. SO MANY OF
US THROUGHOUT OUR DISTRICTS. BUT
I'M REALLY EXCITED I'M FROM
YOU'LL COUNTY DOCTORS THE SUN'S
DONE INCREDIBLE JOB. AND THE
THING THAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT
IS THAT WE'VE BUILT TRUST. AND
ALL. TRUST WITHIN YOUR
COMMUNITIES AND THE STATE
SPONSORED OPTUM SERVES CITING
THE WOODLAND IS SO EXCITING AND
SO MANY PEOPLE ALREADY TALKING
ABOUT IT IS AND I SUPPOSE HAVE A
ONE STOP SHOP. AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON DOING THAT I
WILL BE LOOKING FOR TO SEE HOW
THE DATA GOES HOW MANY PEOPLE
ATTEND. BUT I THINK IT REALLY
HAS TO SAY A LOT TO ALL OF YOU
IS THAT PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO
UNDERSTAND THIS. UNDERSTAND THE
DATA THT'S BEEN PER PROVIDED WE
ONLY CAN GET BETTER BUT WE DO
NEED TO BE READY FOR THAT NEXT
PANDEMIC AND I THINK WE'RE
STARTING TO PUT THOSE STONES
AND- THINGS IN PLACES WE GO
FORWARD TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR YOUR TIME AND THANK YOU FOR
ALL ATTENDING TODAY. K. THING
YOU FOR. NO COME CHECK. WE CAN
MOVE ON. TO THE SECOND PANEL.
AND OVERSEE A LOT OF LESSONS
LEARNED AND IT SOUNDS LIKE
WE'RE- NOT A BETTER PLACE NOW.
HEARING FROM OUR FOLKS ON THE
FIRST PANEL. SO NOW MOVE ON TO
THE SECOND PANEL. REGARDING THE
STATE PROGRESS ON IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE MINISTRATIONS MOTOR
PLANT. SO WITH THAT FIRST LET'S
HEAR FROM DOCTOR THOMAS.
UNDERGONE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA PALM TO PUBLIC
HEALTH. CDPH AND THE STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER- DOCTOR
ARE YOU AVAILABLE. YEAH GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE- YOU TO RETURN
. AND MEMBERS. I'M NOT. MUST ONE
STEP HEALTH OFF. IN DIRECTOR OF
THE CAL. DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH. I THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GIVE YOU AN UPDATE ON
CALIFORNIA'S SMARTER PLAN. THAT
RELEASED ON FOR. SEVENTH OF THIS
YEAR- I WANT TO GIVE. THANKS TO
THE LOW- FOR. HEALTH AND- YEAH.
SYSTEMS AND ASSEMBLYMEMBERS FOR.
EVERYTHING YOU'VE DONE TO
SUPPORT. ALL THAT EFFORTS. I
THINK THEY- FIGHTING THIS PAY.
HAS BEEN A TOTAL. EFFORT IT HAS
BEEN JUST OVER TWO YEARS AND TWO
MONTHS. GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
DECLARED A STATE OF EMERGENCY
FOR CALIFORNIA RESPONSE TO THE
COMPANY. PANDEMIC THAT EMERGE IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY NINETEEN. FOR
WITHIN ONE YEAR- EFFECTIVE
VACCINES AVAIL BY MID DECEMBER
OF TWENTY. IN THE WAY TO TWENTY
ONE WE- A LARGE OF CO NINETEEN
AND WE'VE RAISED DIVAC'S AS MANY
CAL. AS POSSIBLE. AT OUR P. WE
WERE THE MINISTRY ALMOST THREE
MILLION. PER WEEK. GATHER WE
WERE SUCCESSFUL AND WERE ABLE TO
RETIRE THE BLUEPRINT FOR SAFER
ECONOMY ON JUNE FIFTEEN TWENTY
TWENTY. THERE WAS INITIAL.
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES THAT
THE WORD WITH HIGH US. ON STARS
KOBE TO CONTINUE TO ME. AND AT
THE WITH HIM OF NEW VERY. WE
IMPACTED WITH TWO NEW WAVE THE
DELTA. IN THE SUMMER OF TWO ONE
AND THEN THE ALMOST VARIANT IN
THE WINTER OF TWO OF TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. THELMA VARIANT
INVOLVE TO BE A- CAN. AND TO
INVADE IMMUNITY FROM. OR FROM
PRIOR INFO. TOGETHER LISTENING
YOU. RESULTED IN A LARGE NUMBER
OF COVERT THREE. AND MORE. THAN
THE WAY. ALL ACROSS SECTIONS TO.
STAFF SHORTAGES IN MANY
INDUSTRIES INCLUDING
TRANSPORTATION AND HEALTH CARE.
WHILE THE VACCINES ROOM AFFECT
IN PREVENTING HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND DEATH. THE SHEER LARGE
NUMBER OF INFECTIONS ULTIMATELY
ULTIMATELY LED TO A LARGER
NUMBER OF HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
DEATHS. AMONG THE UNVACCINATED
OLDER PERSONS OR PERSONS WITH
UNDERLYING MEDICAL CONDITIONS.
BUT BY THE OMICRON WINTER WAY WE
HAD ACCUMULATED CUMULATED A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF KNOWLEDGE
AND EXPERIENCE VACCINES ARE SAFE
AND EFFECTIVE ESPECIALLY AGAINST
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATH EVEN
AGAINST NEW VARIANTS. PROTECTIVE
IMMUNITY FROM VACCINES FOR PARTY
AFFECTION WANES OVER TIME SO WE
HAD TO ADD A BOOSTER. SARS
COMMITTEE TOO IS AIRBORNE AND
TRANSMITTED VERY EFFICIENTLY IN
INDOOR CITING. MOST OF OR A
SENSE AND ASYMPTOMATIC PERSONS
ARE CONTAGIOUS. FOR THOSE AT THE
BELL SYMPTOMS THEY'RE CONTAGIOUS
TWO DAYS BEFORE THEY DEVELOP
SYMPTOMS. AND THE QUALITY OF THE
MASK MATTERS IS GREAT TO HEAR
ALL THE DISCUSSION ABOUT THE N.
NINETY FIVE. WITH LAYERS OF
PROTECTION IN PLACE CARE CAN BE
OPEN FULL TIME FOR IN PERSON
LEARNING OR HOSPITAL AND EMS
SYSTEMS BECAME OVERWHELMED NOT
JUST FROM COVERT. BUT ALSO FROM
NON KOBE DISEASES THAT- THAT
NEEDED ATTENTION BECAUSE OF THE
LAID CARE WE HAVE STAFF
SHORTAGES ARE FROM FROM KOBE
NINE AND ALSO FROM BURNER. IT
BECAME CLEAR THAT THE SARS KOBE
TO WAS NOT GOING AWAY AND THE
VARIANCE WOULD CONTINUE TO
THREATEN. THAT IS OF IS THAT THE
CASE BECAUSE SARS TO OF THE MEN
IT'S AN X. THE THIEVES. BUT
SOMETHING THAT'S A- ALSO TO
RECOGNIZE IS THAT THIS BEFORE
CALL TO VERY KENNY FALL TO. MORE
SEVERE DISEASE. GIVEN EVERYTHING
THAT WE HAVE LEARNED ABOUT SARS
COULD TO AND THE PIN. WE NEEDED
TO ADOPT MINDSET OUR APPROACH TO
MANAGING COBEN INFECTIONS HOW.
AND DEATH AS WE MOVE INTO THE
FUTURE WE NEEDED TO FINE TUNE
OUR RESPONSE TO THE CURRENT
THREAT. AND OUR READINESS TO
RESPOND TO NEW POTENTIALLY A
MORE DEADLY THREAT. TO CHANGE
THIS WE DEVELOP THE SMARTER PLAN
WHICH YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD THE
ACRONYMS I'M JUST GONNA MENTION
FEW KEY THINGS FROM EACH ONE OF
THE CAT. CATEGORIES SO SHOP. THE
FIRST ONE REPOR OUR FOCUS ON
VACCINE AND IMMUNO. VACCINES ARE
THE MOST POWERFUL WEAPON AGAINST
HOSPITALIZATION AND SEVERE
DISEASE. BUILDING COMMUNITY
IMMUNITIES ARE MOST EFFECTIVE
STRATEGY TO PROTECT HEALTH WE
MUST CONTINUE TO. THE MOST
VULNERABLE VACCINATE. IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES. VACCINATE OUR YOUNG
CHILDREN AS AS THE AS BECAUSE AS
A VACCINE BECOMES AVAILABLE IS
SPECIALLY PREPARING TO VACCINE
THOSE LEFT VACCINATE THOSE LESS
THAN FIVE. AND THEN KEEP KEEP UP
TO DATE WITH OUR- UNDERSTANDING
THE SCIENCE OF IMMUNITY AND AT
THAT. WE HAVE A MINISTER OVER
SEVENTY MILLION DOSES OVER 75%
OF FIVE OF PEEPERS OF OLDER THAN
FIVE HAVE RECEIVED THE PRIMARY
SERIES IN OVER SEVENTY FIVE PER
OF PERSONS. OVER THAN SIX FIVE
HAVE RECEIVED BOOSTERS. IN TERM
OF OUR VACCINE ARE WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO CLOSE THE GAP BETWEEN
THE LOWEST THE LOWEST INCOME
AREAS AND THE HIGHEST INCOME
AREAS CURRENT THE VACCINE
COVERAGE GAP IS ABOUT EIGHT.
PERCENT BUT WE DO NEED TO WE DO
NEED TO GET IT OUT LOWER. IN
TERMS OF A VACCINE COVERAGE
COMPARING LEVINE AND AFRICAN
AMERICANS WHICH ARE ABOUT 958%
COMPARE THE Y. PA. WHAT'S PER
THERE'S A TEMPER. OUR COVERAGE
GAP THERE THAT WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO TRY TO CLOSE AS WELL
. THE NET CATEGORY THAT I'M
GONNA MENTION BRIEFLY IS ABOUT
MATH SO MASS REPRESENTS OUR
FOCUS ON PREVENTING AIRBORNE
TRANSMISSION INDOORS. THE
CONCENTRATION OF VIRUS AEROSOLS
. THE RISK OF INFECTION URSEL
CONCENTRATION INDOORS CAN BE
LOWERED BY INCREASING
VENTILATION FILTERING INDOOR AIR
OR DISINFECTING INDOOR AIR.
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE MASKED
WITH GOOD FIT INFILTRATION.
CAN'T IF INFECTED DECREASE THE
AMOUNT OF VIRUS AEROSOLS THEY
RELEASE INTO THE INDOOR AIR. IF
THEY'RE NOT INFECTED THEY CAN
PROTECT THEMSELVES FROM INHALING
VIRUS AEROSOLS. BECAUSE MANY
INDOOR SPACES ARE POORLY
VENTILATED OR AIR THOUGHT
ADEQUATELY FILTERED THE ONLY. IS
TO WEAR GOOD MATH THIS IS MOST
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE ARE
ARE VULNERABLE AND IN THOSE
SETTINGS WHERE THERE IS A LOT OF
TRANSIT. OR WHERE THERE'S A LOT
OF VOTER. PERSONS WE ARE LOOKING
AT WEAK WEEK WE CONTINUE TO
UPDATE UPDATE OUR MASKING
GUIDANCE AND LOOK AT THE LET THE
LATEST SCIENCE. WE'VE ALSO WE
ALSO WILL BE CONVENIENT INDOOR
AIR QUALITY TASK FORCE TO LEARN
HOW TO REDUCE INDOOR
TRANSMISSION AND TO IMPROVE
INDOOR. AIR QUALITY IN GENERAL.
NOW AWARENESS UP REPRESENTS OUR
FOCUS SURVEY OF PUBLIC
COMMUNICATIONS AND RESEARCH AND
EVALUATION A LOT OF THESE
ELEMENTS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
MENTIONED THINGS LIKE HOLD WHOLE
GENOME SEQUENCING OF WASTEWATER
SURVEILLANCE- ON. A COMBAT HE
MISSED DISINFORMATION I DO WANT
TO POINT OUT THAT WE DEVELOP A
STRONG PARTNERSHIP WITH ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS. UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA TO CONDUCT RESEARCH
ON LONG CODE INTO OTHER RESEARCH
THAT WE UNDERSTAND THE THOUGHT
THE SCIENCE THE SCIENCE OF
TRANSMISSION WE'VE- WITH OVER
TWO. BASED ORGANIZATIONS A THE
STATE TO CONTINUE TO- FOCUS ON
HOW TO MAKE THESE MITIGATION
EFFORTS. BOB ALSO WANT TO
MENTION THAT I'M TO GO TO THE
NEXT CATEGORY WHICH IS READY
KNOWS. THE READING THIS
REPRESENTS OUR FOCUS ON
PREPARING TO RESPOND TO THIRTY
IN CASES OF. AND THE EMERGENCE
OF NEW VARIANTS IT MEANS PARTNER
WITH OUR AGE A THE STATE BOTH
WITH LOCAL HOW SIX. TO BUILD
SYSTEM THAT WE TO GET THINGS
THAT READ MENTIONED GENOME C.
WASTEWATERS ARE. WE HAVE A
STRONG TEAM THAT DOES MATTER
MODELING TO RELIEVE OUR OUR
PREDICTIONS. THE POURING
COMPONENT OF THIS CATEGORY IS A
SUPPORTING HEALTH SYSTEMS AND
YOU'LL HEAR MORE ABOUT THAT
LATER. WITH RESPECT TO TESTING
YOUR HEARD FROM THE LOCALS- HOW
HOW WELL WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO
TO DO TESTING. I WOULD THAT THE
KEY THING THAT I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT FOR TESTING I WANT TO
JUST CALL OUT OF. IN ADDITION TO
PARTY WITH THOUSANDS OF
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE OVER THIRTY
FOUR THOUSAND COMMUNITY SITES.
IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE MAKING
TESTING AVAILABLE HAVE TESTING
FOR THE SCHOOLS. BUT THE X. NEWS
THAT YOU JUST HEARD ABOUT HIS
ARE OFTEN SERVE SITES TO PROVIDE
A ONE STOP SHOP. WHERE YOU CAN
COME IN AND GET TESTED AND BE
PRESCRIBED MEDICATIONS. IF YOU
IF YOU QUALIFY. BOB AND ALTHOUGH
OFTEN SIR SITE THAT'S GOING TO
BE NOW- CLOSE TO A HUNDRED FIFTY
SITES ACROSS. THE STATE. AND OF
COURSE EDUCATION IS SO IMPORTANT
THE KEY THING THAT WE LEARNED
ABOUT EDUCATION. IS THAT WHEN WE
PUT EVERYTHING IN PLACE. THE
INTERVENTIONS ARE SUCCESSFUL AT
KEEPING KIDS IN SCHOOL WE KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT IN. IN PERSON
LEARNING IS FOR SCHOOL
ESPECIALLY FURTHER EMOTIONAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH. AND THEN THE LAST
CATEGORY IS TREE. THIS IS REALLY
THE TIER FOR ALL OF US BECAUSE
AS NIETZSCHE BECOME AVAILABLE WE
KNOW THAT IF YOU DO IF YOU
BECOME IN FACT IN YOU TO.
SYMPTOMS YOU HAVE TO START. WITH
FIVE DAYS OF. AS SO IN ADDITION
TO PROVIDING- OUT OF- CALLED MY
- A BY. AT THE MAKE YOUR OWN BIT
ABOUT THIS LATER WERE PUSH THE
AVAILABILITY OF A PACK LOW THE
WORLD. WHICH IS VERY EFFECTIVE
IN KEEPING PERSONS OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL. AND THE LAST I WANT TO
MENTION ABOUT THE- IS AT WORK. A
HELL SYSTEMS INTO. WORK FOR. TO
REALLY FROM. THANK YOU. THE HELL
CARE SO ACROSS IS. IN OR SAFETY
TO ASSIST. TO BE MORE. AND
PROVIDING. TO TRY. IT AT THE
IT'S IMPROVING- TED TO TREAT
PROGRAMS SO THAT WE HAVE AS MUCH
AVAILABLE TO EVERYBODY. IN CLOSE
. THIS PLAN WAS THIS TO THE-
LEARNED OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
AND ON CALIFORNIA SUCCESSES. IT
IS FLEXIBLE BY DESIGN SO THAT WE
CAN RESPOND QUICKLY AS THE VIRUS
CHANGES. WE MEETING THE GOALS
OUTLINED IN A SMARTER PLAN AND
CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH CONFIDENCE
THAT WE CAN RESPOND TO WHATEVER
CO THE NINETEEN HAS IN STORE FOR
US. AND TO KEEP PEOPLE HEALTHY
AND OUT OF THE HOSPITALS WHICH
WILL KEEP CALIFORNIA OPEN. AND
WE ARE USING THE SMARTER PLAN TO
RESPOND NOT JUST TO THIS CURRENT
STAGE. BUT ALSO TO HELP US FOR
ANY TYPE OF RESPIRATORY PATHOGEN
THAT WE MIGHT FACE IN THE FUTURE
. ALTHOUGH SMARTER PLAN FOCUSING
ON KOBE NINETEEN THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED HELPS US FOR OTHER
OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES
BEYONC BEYOND COVERAGE I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE AN UPDATE WITH CITY PH
THE PROGRESS AND I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR NOW MOVES TO
THE SECOND- MEMBER- BASSINET
ACTING DIRECTOR FROM RIDGE
MEDICAL THIRTY EMSA. LIVED ARE
YOU THERE. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. GREAT GOOD MORNING JERRY
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT THIS
TOPIC IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU ALL
AGAIN. I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO START WITH WHAT WE HAVE
LEARNED AND HOW THAT'S
CONTRIBUTED TO OUR PREPAREDNESS
APPROACH TO. OVER THE OF THE PNW
WE'VE LEARNED A TREMENDOUS. IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM. WE KNOW TODAY
ABOUT A SINGULAR- APPROACH TO
SUPPORT THE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM IS NOT AS A BACK. AS A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO JUST.
A LITTLE BIT THE HEALTHCARE
CONTINUUM CONTINUUM IS GENERALLY
MADE UP OF THREE MAJOR PARTS
THAT CAN. COMPARED HOW. SO THE
FRONT DOOR OF THE HOUSE IS HOW
CARE THIS IS A E. M. SYSTEM. IS
THE HOUSE IS THE Q. CARE. THAT
INTENSIVE CARE YOU. LET ME TREE
IN MY SURGE FLOOR OF A HOT. IN
THE BACK DOOR OF THE HOUSE IS
DISCHARGING DECOMPRESSION OF A
HOSPITAL TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
PATIENTS TO STEP DOWN CARE
FACILITIES. OR HOME THE ON THEIR
- WHAT ALL THREE PARTS OF THAT
CONTINUUM ARE WORKING PROPERLY
ARE NOT BURDENED THAT I PAID IS
ABLE TO MOVE THE CONTINUE ON.
WITHOUT DELAY. WE HAVE FOUND
SUCCESS IN SUPPORTING OUR
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM WE
TAKE THAT COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
BUILT AROUND AND HE CAN SING
CAPACITY EACH PART OF THE
CONTENT. SO CAPACITY TO
TRANSPORT PATIENTS CAPACITY TO
HAVE PROVIDERS CARE FOR PATIENTS
AND CAPACITY TO DISCHARGE
PATIENTS OUT OF THE HOSPITAL.
YOU SAW THAT APPROACH IN OUR
RESPONSE TO OMICRON TO THE
OVERCROWDED AREA WE HAD OVER
TWENTY AMBULANCE PATIENT OFFLOAD
TEAMS SUPPORTING THE FRONT OF
THE HOUSE STATE WHY WE HAD OVER
THIRTY FIVE CLINICAL CON THIRTY
FIVE HUNDRED CLINICAL CARE
CONTRACTS STAFF. SUPPORTING OVER
TWO HUNDRED HOSPITAL STATE WIDE
AND WE HAD OVER THREE HUNDRED
STAFF DEPLOYED TO SUPPORT
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
FACILITIES AT THE BACK DOOR.
THIS COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
SUPPORTING THE HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM IS EFFECTIVE IN
ENSURING ENSURING PATIENTS MOVE
THROUGH THE CONTINUE ON AND
THERE'S NO BOTTLENECK IN THE
SYSTEM WHICH CAN HINDER OPTIMAL
PATIENT CARE. IF WE HAD ONLY
SUPPORTED THE HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM WITH THE PLAYING
A POT TEAM DURING THE LAST
WINTER. THE BURDEN WITH BEEN
SHIFTED FROM THE FRONT DOOR OF
THE HOUSE TO INSIDE OF THE HOUSE
WHICH WOULD HAVE CREATED ANOTHER
BOTTLENECK BY INCREASING THE
PATIENT'S SYSTEM CENSUS AND
INPATIENT SETTING WITH NOT
ENOUGH. TO CARE FOR THEM. THE
RESPONSE DURING EACH SURGE AND
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM HAS TAUGHT US
THAT PATIENT THROUGHPUT IS
GENERALLY THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT FACTOR IN MITIGATING
SEARCH. AS THE SMARTER PLAN LAYS
OUT WE ARE POISED AND READY TO
SUPPORT OUR HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM AND THE COMPREHENSIVE WAY
IN THIS COMPREHENSIVE WAY. AS A
SMARTER PLAN OUTLINES WE HAVE
SEVERAL CONTRACTS WHICH WILL
HELP SUPPORT OUR GOAL OF
DEPLOYING UP TO THREE THOUSAND
CLINICAL STAFF WITHIN WO TO
THREE WEEKS TO VARIOUS TYPES OF
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES.
ADDITIONALLY WE CONTINUE OUR
PREPAREDNESS AND READY NETWORK
WITH THE HEALTHCARE. SYSTEM IN
THESE MOMENTS IN APRIL OF THIS
YEAR WE SENT OUT SURVEYS TO A
PORTION OF FACILITIES AND THOSE
WHO UTILIZE OUR STAFF TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN BETTER
ADAPT OUR- AND WE CONTINUE TO DO
THAT WE COLLECT RESPONSES HAVE
CONVERSATIONS. IN ORDER TO
UNDERSTAND THE GENERAL
EFFECTIVENESS IN UTILIZATION OF
THE STAFF. WITH THIS I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. NOW WITH
THE- DEPUTY DIRECTOR HELD IS
OFTEN. HI THIS IS A MUCH BETTER
GET A CHICKEN CAN YOU HEAR ME IN
SENIOR OKAY. EIGHT THANK YOU I.
N. GOOD MORNING MS CHAIR MISTER
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY ON ON- ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S. OFFICE EMERGED. OUR
FIRST EMERGENCY SERVICES ROLE IN
IMPLEMENTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PLAN- CALAVERAS IS BEEN PART OF
A LARGER TASK FORCE AND WE- IN
SUPPORTING THIS PLAN AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO- THOSE MEMBERS
INCLUDING G. S. C. D. PH.
MILITARY MS- THEME ON. OTHER
PHONE PARTNERS THAT WORK WITH US
IN SOME- AS A KNOWS THE- YOUR IN
CALIFORNIA THE NAY THE NATION
THE WORLD DEALT WITH EXTREME BP
- AND MEDICAL SUPPLIES THE EARLY
DAYS OF THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC AND
AS WITH ANY CRISIS. IN CERTAIN
CERTAINLY- WITH THE CODEPENDENT
MAKE WE HAD TO BE PURPOSEFUL AND
TIMELY AND ACT ACCORDINGLY HAVE
CONTINGENCY IS IN PLACE. AND
GIVEN THE SIZE. OF CALIFORNIA
AND ITS PPM MEDICAL NEEDS FOR
HEALTHCARE AND IT'S WORKERS
FIRST RESPONDERS AND OTHER
SERVICES- WE DEVELOPED A MULTI
PRONGED APPROACH AND IT WAS A
SUSTAINABLE STRATEGIES AT TO
MEET RESOURCE NEEDS. FOR THE
DURATION OF THIS EVENT AND FOR
THE FUTURE- OF THIS MULTI
PRONGED APPROACH- TO SECURE PP
AND SUPPLIES INCLUDED PURCHASING
OUT FROM STOCKS AND SUPPLIERS.
AND DONATIONS- STATE AND FEDERAL
STOCKPILES LEVERAGING- NGOS
ANOTHER COMMUNITY WORK. SELL
GOVERNMENT APPROACH AND- AND
THIS WORKED VERY EFFECTIVELY.
OWNS COURSE THE KEY THING IS
THAT WE'VE LEARNED THROUGH THESE
EXPERIENCES WE CAN'T GO BACK THE
WAY THINGS WERE PRIOR TO
PANDEMIC. THE MEDICAL PUBLIC
HEALTH ENVIRONMENTS HAVE BEEN
PROPERLY CHANGE AND WE NEED TO
CONTINUE THE EFFORTS TO PROPERLY
PREPARE AND RESPOND. TO FUTURE
REQUIREMENTS. THESE EFFORTS ARE
ONGOING UNDER WHAT WE CALL THE
READING THIS PORTION OF THE
GOVERNOR SMARTER PLAN- BUT IT
WAS NOT EASILY. EASY INITIALLY
BUILDING THE FOUNDATION FOR
SUSTAINABLE SUPPLY PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE CONTINUES TO
REQUIRE THE COORDINATED EFFORT
AMONG MULTI AGENCIES AND
PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE HAVE
ESTABLISH INCLUDING- NOT
PREVIOUSLY LISTED- OUR TRIBAL
PARTNERS- THIS WORKERS LEFT IS
FINALLY NOW WITH THE SUSTAINABLE
AND RELIABLE LOGISTICS. PIPELINE
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO BE USED IN
THE FUTURE. RAPID DEPLOYMENT OF
PP AND MEDICAL SUPPLIES IS
CRITICAL THE HEALTH SECTOR
CRITICAL THE FIRST RESPONDERS
AND CRITICAL FRONTLINE WORKERS
WHEN COMMUNITIES ARE NEED. AND
OTHER FOR HEALTH CARE- HAS HAD
BEEN IT CAN. TO BE DISTRIBUTED-
HER OUR PREPAY AND THEN PROCESS
AND HEALTH CARE FACILITIES
CONTINUE SMITH- RESEARCH RICK
TO. THEY GO TO THEIR THROUGH
THEIR NOW. HEALTH AREA
COORDINATORS AND IF THEY SOURCES
BECOMES UP TO THE STATE AND WE
ELEVATED ACCORDINGLY AND THEN.
AND THEN SUPPORT THEM BACK SO.
WE'VE CREATED A SYSTEM THAT IS
TIMELY THREES. AND REALLY
SUPPORTS OUR STAKEHOLDERS- A
COUPLE EXAMPLES THAT TOOK PLACE
FIRST ON THAT WHERE'S OTHER MOST
RECENT SPORT WAS WITHOUT THEIR
BOARD OF EDUCATION AND THE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION A
DIFFERENT LAW SCHOOLS OF PP AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE FALL TWENTY
TWENTY SCHOOLS OR- WE DID THIS
IN COORDINATION AND PUSH THAT
OUT RAPIDLY. WE'VE ALSO DONE IT
WITH THE DEPARTMENT FOOD
AGRICULTURE TO SERVE ACT FOR
WORKERS IN CENTRAL ALONG THE
COAST. AND WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
THE DIVISION OF OUR SAFETY.
HEALTH AND THE CALIFORNIA OF
PUBLIC HEALTH- ON STRIDES THAT
ARE WORK. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN SUPPORT ACCORDING- ALL.
ESTABLISH PROCESS ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE IN THE FUTURE UNDER
GOVERNOR SMARTER PLAN. OUR STATE
OUR CENTER BEEN ACT NOW OVER
HUNDRED. RISK TO THE GRAND. AND
THE EFFECTIVE JUST OF PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT- CONTINUES
AND IS IT IS SUCH A CRITICAL
MISSION. FOR A TO SERVE- SINCE
OF THE PANDEMIC WE'VE- A TOTAL.
OF OVER ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION
PIECES OF PP AND RELATE RE- TO
COMBATING SPREAD OF CODE
NINETEEN- IN TWENTY TWENTY TO-
WE'VE ALREADY SHOULD BE MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE
MILLION. HE SAYS- ARE
FORTUNATELY OUR NUMBERS CONTINUE
TO GO OUR REQUEST CONTINUE GO
DOWN AND THIS IS A GOOD SIGN OF
THE RESILIENCY THAT'S BEEN BUILT
AT ALL LEVELS- THROUGHOUT. OUR
HEALTH COMMUNITY I WITH THAT I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER. ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU MADE FOR THE
PRESENTATION THAT WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I
DO HAVE JUST A TWO QUICK
QUESTIONS TO ASK ANYBODY MAYBE
ON THE ON THE- SECOND PANEL-
HOW'S THE STATE MEASURING.
SUCCESSES AND PROVIDE IN ECUADOR
SPONSOR- THROUGH THE SMARTER
PLAN IN IN OUR- COUNTIES AND
MEASURE THAT. AND HOW WE'RE
LOOKING TO MAKE IT. MORE
EQUITABLE ACROSS THE BOARD. HI
THIS IS DOCTOR ARE GONE SO THAT
THE KEY WHERE THEY WERE THE THIS
IS. THERE'S TWO TWO MAJOR WAYS
WERE DOING THE THINGS. ARE USING
WITH A HEALTHY PLACES INDEX THAT
COMPARES. DIFFERENT AREAS ACROSS
THE NIGHT I'M SORRY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA BASED ON- THE
RESOURCES MOSTLY IF IT HASN'T
HIGHER INCOME AND LOW INCOME.
AND SO WE HAVE WE HAVE FOUND
THAT. THAT WHAT WILL WHAT PEOPLE
REFER TO AS HPI HPI ONE IS THE
LOWEST INCOME H. P. I. TWO IS
THE NEXT LOWEST INCOME. H. P. I.
FOUR IS THE HIGHEST INCOME. WE
FOUND DURING THE PANDEMIC THAT
THESE THAT THESE CATEGORIES WERE
THAT WERE AMONG THE STRONGEST
PREDICTORS OF THE COVE IT. A
CASE OF THE HOSPITALIZATIONS WE
ALSO KNOW THAT IT ALSO
CORRELATES WITH THE RACIAL AND
ETHNIC DISTRIBUTION OF
COMMUNITIES. CALIFORNIA SO WE'VE
BEEN WITH TERM OF DISTRIBUTING.
DURING OUR CAMPAIGNS- IN MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE SITES WE
REALLY FOCUS ON CLOSING THE GAPS
BECAUSE IT WE DID OBSERVE. THAT
H. P. I. FOR WAS MORE SUCCESSFUL
IN. AND HAVING HIGH COVERAGE AND
THEN WE INVEST A LOT OF
RESOURCES IN THOSE LOWER INCOME
AREAS H. B. R. ONE INTO TWO.
THAT EQUITY CAP. THE OTHER WAY
THAT WE FOCUS ON THAT WE ALSO
LOOK AT THE DATA- BY RACE
ETHNICITY. AND WE'VE WORKED WITH
OVER TWO HUNDRED- CBO'S ACROSS
THE STATE TO REALLY GET THE
MESSAGE OUT. ON A LOT HAS BEEN
INVESTED IN THE IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CAMPAIGN TO GET FOLKS
VACCINATED FIGHTING- A MIS AND
DISINFORMATION HAS BEEN AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT. THE LAST
SECTION I WANT TO ALSO MENTION
WHICH IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
EQUITY IS. IS WORKING WITH
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE STATE
ESPECIALLY THE PUBLIC PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. MAKING SURE THEY WERE
ABLE TO GET KIDS IN SCHOOL AND
MAKE IT A SAFE POSSIBLE BECAUSE
FAMILIES WANT TO SEND THEIR KIDS
TO SCHOOL IF THEY FEEL THAT.
THEIR KIDS ARE GOING TO BE SAFE
IN SCHOOL. THAT'S BEEN AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT EQUITY
PERSPECTIVE FROM A MENTAL.
HEALTH PERSPECTIVE FROM ALERTING
LOS FIRST INTO FROM AN- PER. IN
SUPPORT THESE CAN. THANK YOU AND
THE NEXT PERSON HAD REALLY AND
MAYBE LET YOU HAVE CONTROL OVER
IT BUT- JUST WANT TO FOLLOW UP
DO WE HAVE A PLAN TO MAINTAIN
EXISTING FROM LIKE WORK WORK
FORCE FOR FUTURE COVERT-
NINETEEN OUTBREAKS OR PUBLIC
HEALTH THREATS HOW DO WE LOOK TO
MEASURE THAT TO MAINTAIN- THE
WORK FORCE. WELL I THINK THAT'S
A GREAT QUESTION I THINK AS YOU
KNOW NOT JUST HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THIS IS A STRUGGLE GLOBALLY AS
WE TRY TO. MAINTAIN THIS
WORKFORCE THEIR BURNOUT AND ALL
THESEOTHER THINGS OBVIOUSLY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET WE HAVE.
DIFFERENT WORKFORCE INITIATIVES
WITH IN PARTNERSHIP WITH L. W.
D. A. AS WELL AS- WORKING TO
UNDERSTAND AND PARTNER WITH
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL. TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THESE NEEDS BUT I THINK. THIS
WILL TAKE A LONGER TERM- IF
VISION THAT REALLY SEEKS TO
BUILD A PIPELINE OF THE WORK
FORCE OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
OKAY THANK YOU- VICE CERTAINLY
OF. HI COUPLE QUESTIONS HERE- SO
THE- LET'S TALK ABOUT
DISTRIBUTION OF THE PP WALK
WHERE DOES IT DO WE HAVE A
CENTRAL WAREHOUSE IN CALIFORNIA
IS IT UP TO THE COUNTIES TO HAVE
DISTRIBUTION. I MEAN SUPPLY
WAREHOUSES THAT- PP E. CAN BE
DISTRIBUTOR FROM WHEN WE DO HAVE
SURGES IN HOSPITALS- RUN BEHIND
IN BEING ABLE TO ORDER- FROM
VARIOUS WHOEVER THEY ORDER FROM
TO GET THEIR PP. ALEX GREAT
QUESTION- SO- AT. STATE LEVEL WE
MAY TO WHERE I- AND CONJUNCTION
ARE PRIMARY SOURCE OF P. ONE IS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND ONE IS
IN NORTH CALIFORNIA- AND BOTH OF
THOSE LOCATIONS- SO. AND PUSH TP
A DOWN. THE REGION OR THE COUNTY
MORLOCKS- AS REQUESTED FOR THEIR
SUPPLIES NOW WE KEEP THEM
STOCKED AT A LEVEL THAT THEY'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH AND THEY SET
THOSE TARGETS- AND WE ALSO
SUPPORT DIRECTLY TO OUR EASTER
AND CUSTOMERS AS WELL SO. WE DO
KIND OF A FULL STOP- SHOP WELL
SUPPORTING EVERYBODY THERE- THIS
WAY WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT- THE
LOCAL OUR LOCAL PARTNERS ARE
ADEQUATELY STOCKED IN RESOURCE
TO BE WHEN THERE'S EVENTS THAT
ARE BEYOND. THEIR CURRENT
STOCKPILES THAT THEY HAVE.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHEN I THE REALLY
THINGS IS TO ENSURE THAT AS
THEIR NEEDS FLUCTUATE AND
CHANGE- THERE IS AN IMMEDIATE
SOURCE OF- OF- I HAVE TO GET TO
ACQUIRE THEIR PP FROM. AND AS
YEAR. I THINK HAVING A NORTH AND
THE SOUTH IS GREAT IF THE
COUNTIES ARE INVOLVED IN HAVE
THEIR OWN- SO THAT WE HAVE SOME
CHECK AND BALANCES BUT WE ALSO
HAVE TO ENSURE. THAT THOSE SOME
THAT ARE WAY. ARE BEING. OUT AT
A KIND OF HAS A END DATE TO IT
AND- YOU DON'T WANT TO. A P. P.
E. THAT IS A OR YEARS THE SHELF
- GETTING SENT OUT AND- A LOT OF
TIMES THAT THAT TYPE OF THING
HOW DO YOU GUYS ENSURE THAT THAT
DOES NOT HAPPEN. I WE ARE
WINNING. IT'S A GREAT CAR.
BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS A LIFE
CYCLE AND SO- WE ARE VERY
CLOSELY- THROUGH LIFE MANAGEMENT
TO TRY TO- MAXIMIZE- THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THOSE RESTORE.
MAKE A- AS A TO THE END OF THEIR
DATE- AND THEN PUSH THEM INTO.
FOR OUR REPURPOSE THEM INTO
OTHER AREAS- WHICH WE MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO USE- SUCH AS A BASED
BASE COVERING. AFTER IT'S NO
LONGER ABLE TO BE USED IN
SURGICAL SETTING UP- THAT TOO WE
WOULD USE FOR OUR MAY. COMMUNITY
SO WE HAVE TO CLOSELY MONITOR-
EXPIRING. AND LOOK AT THOSE
DATES- AND THEN- ALL- TO DO OUR
BEST TO. NOT HAVE TO NEXT AND
FIND THE RIGHT TARGET. TO MAKE
SURE THAT- AS A SHOCK ABSORBER-
WITHIN THE SYSTEM NETWORK. ON
THE LAST STICKING NATURE IN THAT
WERE RESPONDING. AND NOT RUNNING
SHORT AND NOT HAVING TOO MUCH SO
IT'S A- ONE WE ARE. ABOUT HOW TO
MAINTAIN- YOU KNOW CLOSE. OF
AWARENESS OF. THE FUTURE
PANDEMICS. THE RIGHT TARGET
WHAT'S BEEN PREVIOUSLY USED- AND
IT AND THERE THE SAME TIME. I
WILL SAY HOSPITALS NOW INCREASE
THEIR STORAGE. THE REGION'S OF
AGREE SIR STORAGE THE CALORIES
INCREASE OR STORAGE ALL OF THAT
EVERYBODY IS. RESPONDED SINCE-
TWENTY TWENTY SO THERE'S A- MUCH
BETTER- STOCKPILE OF SITUATIONAL
. AND I CAN. ACROSS THE BOARD
AND SO WE JUST MOVE FASTER NOW
THAT WE HAVE- AND HAVE IN THE
PAST AND IT'S JUST INCUMBENT ON
US TO. MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
REGRESS- JANE. THAT KEEP THE
BILL THE FUTURE FOR. THE FUTURE
EVENTS ARE TYPE. RIGHT I THINK
THAT BUT SUBJECT IN ITSELF IS
SOMETHING THAT WE COULD PROBABLY
HAVE A- BETTER DISCUSSION ON HOW
TO HANDLE GOING INTO THE FUTURE
BECAUSE I THINK THERE ARE SOME
WAYS OF. CHANGING THE WAY WE DO
THINGS TO BETTER MANAGE THIS
THIS. THIS TYPE OF SURGE THAT WE
GET NOW- AND GOING INTO THE
FUTURE BECAUSE OF- OF COVERT I
WANT TO SWITCH TO REALLY QUICK.
OF FACILITIES- RIGHT NOW THE
SEARCH FOR HOSPITALS IS HANDLE.
SOMETIME THE TENTS. OF SOMETIMES
WITH DELAYING PATIENT TREATMENT
FOR- WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
CONSIDERED TO BE ELECTIVE
SURGERIES AND THINGS LIKE THAT
AND IT REALLY DISRUPTS THE
MEDICAL CARE FOR EVERYONE ELSE.
AND I THINK. THE STATE HAS TO
TAKE A ROLE IN FIGURING OUT
GOING INTO THE FUTURE HOW WE'RE
GOING TO HANDLE SURGE ON A
PERMANENT. BASIS. BYE BYE MAYBE
EVEN PART. AND HAVE HOSP CAMP.
THAT HAVE. A B. MS IS ONE ONE
PERSON WAS SPEAKERS I THINK IT'S
MISS BASSINET. SPOKE YOU KNOW
THE- NG WELL WE TO A- TO SOME OF
CAMPUS THAT CAN HANDLE. KOBE
WHEN IT SIR. AND THE STAY WRIST
OF. SHOULD BE TO ABLE TO GET
THOSE TYPE OF FACILITIES BILL.
SO THIS THE HOSPITAL'S FOLK ON
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO WHICH IS TO
GROW THEIR COME. NOT SEARCH
COMPARE. FOR A- BECAUSE
OTHERWISE THEY GET SWITCHED INTO
DOING THAT AND THE COMMUNITY
GROWTH FALLS BEHIND AND THEN
THEY BECOME INADEQUATE- EVEN FOR
THEIR MOST BASIC SERVICES FOR
THEIR COMMUNITIES. SO THAT'S
SOMETHING I THINK WE SHOULD ALSO
BE LOOKING AT GOING INTO THE
FUTURE I DON'T KNOW IF THERE WAS
A QUESTION IN THERE BUT- MORE OF
A THOUGHT PROCESS. YEAH OKAY
THEM WITH THAT I JUST HAD ONE
LAST QUESTION JUST CAME TO MIND-
WITH THE USE OF- OR I SHOULD SAY
THE HOME TESTS BECOME MORE
AVAILABLE FOR FOLKS PURCHASING A
KEVIN AMOUNT HOME DOES THE
SMARTER PLAN ACCOUNT FOR ANY
POTENTIAL- TESTED COME POSITIVE
OR NEGATIVE ON THAT I KNOW
THEY'RE GOING TO FROM HOME AT
DIFFERENT SO HOW DOES THAT
ACCOUNT FOR WITH THE SMARTER
PLAN YEAH THIS IS A VERY GOOD
QUESTION- IT HAVING THE
AVAILABILITY HOME TESTING IS SO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY CAN BE
USED FOR MULTIPLE PURPOSES IF
YOU'VE BEEN EXPOSED IF YOU
DEVELOP SYMPTOMS. YOU CAN TESTER
SET YOU CAN TEST YOURSELF PRE
EVENT BEFORE YOU GO VISIT- TECH
TO BEFORE YOU GO HAVE A SOCIAL
INDOOR GATHERING SO I THINK
IMPORTANT ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
OF CONTESTS OF COURSE IS THAT
WHEN THEY TEST POSITIVE IT
DOESN'T END UP IN OUR
SURVEILLANCE. SO- BUT THE PEOPLE
CAN STILL USE THAT POSITIVE TO
GET TREATMENT THEY DO THAT-
POSITIVE TEST THE IT IN THE WILL
THEY WILL THEY WILL BE TO GET
TREATMENT AT THAT'S THE BEST WAY
TO THE- REALLY. PAULFOR ALL OF
US BECAUSE YOU WANT TO HAVE YOU
WANT TO START TREATMENT AS SOON
AFTER YOU DEVELOP- OTHER
SYMPTOMS ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE AT
RISK SO THE OTHER THING I JUST
WANT TO MENTION OF THE CHALLENGE
WHICH IS BECAUSE OUR
SURVEILLANCE. ARE BASED ON THE
CASE COUNT THAT WE HAVE ARE
BASED ON PRIMARILY THE PEOPLE
PRIMARILY PCR TESTS THAT ARE IN
OUR SYSTEM SO THE CURRENT CASE
COUNTS CHEESE THAT WE'RE
REPORTING ARE RIGHT NOW OVER
TIME DOES UNDER ESTIMATE THE
AMOUNT OF TRANSITION THAT'S
HAPPENING AND SO THAT'S PART OF
WHAT WE TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WHAT
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT- OUR OUR
GUIDANCE IS RECOGNIZING THAT
WERE UNDER COUNTY THERE'S MORE
TRANSMISSION HAPPENING THE
COMMUNITY THANK YOU SEE FROM THE
OFFICIAL COUNTS BECAUSE THAT
ONLY THAT'S ONLY THE PEOPLE. THE
PCR TEST ARE BEING. COUNTED OKAY
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FOR SURE. NO WAY. THE OWNER
THANK POWER FROM POWER FOR YOUR
TIME. AND GIVING US A QUICK
UPDATE ON THE GOVERNOR SMARTER
PLANT SO. OBVIOUSLY LOOKS LIKE
WE'RE IN A BETTER POSITION OR
MAYBE A COUPLE THINGS TO WORK ON
MINOR LEAGUE BUT- FOR THE MOST
PART I THINK- HE PLAN. IS DO
WHAT IT'S INTENDED TO DO
ESPECIALLY TO PROVIDE CARE
SERVICE TREATMENT TO OUR FOLKS
IN ALL OUR COUNTIES. SO AT THAT
WE WILL GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT-
DID ARE TIME CONSTRAINTS WILL.
PUBLIC COME TO ONE MAN- WITHOUT
CAN WE TO THE- OPERA. OPERATOR
WE DID OPEN UP FOR. ON THE LINE.
IS OR ANYBODY ON THE LINE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
LATER GENTLEMEN TO. MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE.
NAY T. SPECIALIST WILL. YOU WITH
YOUR NUMBER. AND WE'LL CALL OPEN
YOUR LINE WOULD READY. WELL FOR
GO TO LINE. TEN DEMOCRATS COUNTY
I OPPOSE EVERYTHING YOU HAVE
SAID THIS IS OVER REACH. WE HAVE
BRIGHT IN THIS COUNTRY THANK YOU
PEOPLE ARE. PUTTING IN WHAT YOU
THINK IS RIGHT AND WHAT WE THINK
IS WRONG PLEASE STAY BACK
NATURAL AROUND. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OPERATOR ANYONE ELSE. BLINDS
I WON SEVEN OF THAT MEETING I
GUESS I'M LUCKY NUMBER SEVEN
BECAUSE THE CORRUPTION NEVER
STOPS DOWN THERE IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
TO SPEND OUR MONEY ON THIS SHAM
OF AN EMERGENCY IF YOU DIDN'T
GET THE MEMO FORTY OTHER STATES
AND- WE'LL GO TO ONE SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU. THE MORNING CHAIRMAN
MY NAME IS MARK ASPECT THE
COUNTY EXECUTIVE THE OF POWER
REPRESENTING THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT THAT THE PATIENT
WOULDLIKE THINK THEIR SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR SMARTER PLAN I
WOULD LIKE TO UNDERSCORE THE
COMMENTS MADE BY DR DAVIS AND DR
SUSTAIN REGARDING THE LOCAL
HEALTH IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PLANTS AND THE CHALLENGES WITH
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF OUR
WORKFORCE EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT HAS FACED SIGNIFICANT
WORKFORCE CHALLENGES WHERE FEWER
THAN ONE IN SIX GRADUATES FROM
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH GOAL TO
WORK AND GO. MEDICAL PUBLIC
HEALTH THE COMPANY CONDEMN HAS
EXACERBATED THE CHALLENGES AND
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS BROUGH
WITH BERNARD IN EFFECT AND
HARASS WELL I'LL BEING HEAVILY
WORK BY OTHER SECTORS WE'RE
REQUESTING THE TO PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE RECRUITMENT RETENTION
AND TRAINING PROPOSAL AS A KEY
CA OF CALIFORNIA MARK PLAN
INSURE THAT WE NEED PLAN A WORK
WORK COMPARED TO RESPOND TO
COOLEY NINETEEN AND OTHER PUBLIC
HEALTH THREAT THANK. YOU THANK
YOU. OPERATOR ON ELSE. LINE YES
I AM CALLING ABOUT THE MURDER
PLAN AND I REALLY WISH THE
GOVERNOR WOULD LOOK AT THE DATE
THAT WERE SUCCESSFUL LIKE LORD
ACTON SAID AND IT THERE PLANS
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T. PROBABLY
HEALTH HAD FAILED A THE PUBLIC
IS NOT. PUBLIC HEALTH. AT ALL
THERE HAS BEEN TOO MANY DEATHS
ITS APPLICATIONS PUBLIC HEALTH
SUCH AS NOT GIVING UP ON A READ
. H. TRAFFIC. AND ALSO THE FIELD
MATH. MANDATE AND CRASHING HIS
WE DIDN'T ALLOW ANY PUBLIC
HEALTH I WE SHOULD NOT ARM WITH
ANY TYPE OF MANDATE OR LET. OR
ON ENFORCEMENT AND MARTYR WILL
ONLY FOR GUESSTIMATE. HANIF CAL
. AND A PRESS PEOPLE AND IF IT
IS THE CITIZENS DO NOT ONE THIS
THANK YOU. I EIGHT. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE CHAIR THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- I'M NOT SURE
IF THE SMARTER PLAN INVOLVES
MANDATING ANY TREATMENT OR
PURELY RECOMMENDATIONS BUT THIS
REALLY CONCERNS ME AS A
CONSTITUENT AND THAT'S OUR
GOVERNOR IS AN ADVOCATE FOR
CHOICE I DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD
USE- BUSINESSES AS LIKE TO CALL
THE POLICE FOR THE STATE-
BUSINESSES HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ENFORCE MASS WITHOUT A STATE
MASS MANDATE AND THEY CAN ALSO
MAKE THEIR OWN PRIVATE POLICIES.
THAT CAN RESULT IN TRESPASSING
CHARGES FOR THOSE NOT WEARING
THE MASK I'M I'M MORE CONCERNED
THAT OUR CHILDREN ARE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO A SPEECH
IMPEDIMENT RATHER THAN A VIRUS
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
NINETY NINE POINT 995% CHANCE OF
SURVIVING AND THAT MAKES ME
QUESTION WHY WE NEED THE
GOVERNMENT TO TELL US WHAT'S BAD
AND I THINK IT CLEARLY HAD DON'T
WORK AND THERE'S NO SENSE IN IT
ESPECIALLY WHEN TWO WEEKS BECAME
MONTHS AND THEN YEARS. AND I YOU
GUYS ARE THE ONLY ONES WHO CAN
ANSWER WHETHER THE STATE WAS
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT PEOPLE
STATE YOU'RE NOT- WHAT KEEPING
PEOPLE SAFE WE ALSO MANAGED TO
CLOSE DOWN AROUND 36% OF OUR
BUSINESSES AND IT'S THE NUMBER
THAT HARD YOU KNOW GAVE US FROM
AGO. IT'S PROBABLY CLOSER. ARE
YOU IMPOSING RESTRICTIONS ON
CITIZENS THANK YOU. THE ONE ELSE
. NINE ELEVEN. I FELT ONE THING
I DID NOT HEAR I'M NOT WITH ALL
OF THE EXPERTS THAT CAME FORWARD
WAS ANY KIND OF EVOLUTION WITH
THE SCIENCE IT'S COMING OUT
FIZER DOCUMENTS HAVE BEEN
DROPPING WE HAD ANOTHER EIGHT
EIGHTY THOUSAND PAGES DUMPED
AFTER THEY WERE BASICALLY FEUD
WITH A FOUR YEAR RELEASED BY
DISCOVERED BOXING WAS NOT 95%
EFFECTIVE AS THEY CLEAN THE DATA
SHOWS THAT HAVE THE 12% EFFICACY
RATE FOR THE FIRST SEVEN DAYS
AND THEN FAILED TO LEAD TO ONE
PERCENT. THAT'S IN THE DOCUMENTS
I DIDN'T HEAR ANYTHING FROM ANY
OF THE PEOPLE THEY PROPOSED IT
IS BEING THE BEST SOLUTION
MOVING FORWARD AND HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE. READ RIGHT THAT DATA
THEY WERE NO HE CLINICAL TRIALS
TO DETERMINE IF THE EXPERIMENTAL
JOBS WERE SAFE FOR PREGNANT
WOMEN. IT WAS EXCLUDED FROM ALL
TRIALS INSTEAD THEY CAPTURED ON
FORTY FOUR RAP RAP. BEFORE
CLAIMING IT WAS SAFE THERE ARE A
TOTAL OF NINE SITES REVEALED OF
THE HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT ONLY SIX
POINT 6% OF THE SUBJECTS. ARE
BEING PRESENTED FOR THE DATA SO
THERE'S STILL A LOT TO LEARN.
THE LIPID NANOPARTICLES WERE
FOUND HAD DISTRIBUTED THROUGHOUT
THE BODY IN THE LIVER OVER YOU
CAN OTHER VITAL ORGANS. FORTY
EIGHT HOURS POST INJECTION. I
HEARD B- THE TAX LAW THAT BEING
REFERENCE TO THE FACT THAT GET
VISOR SAYS. OPERATOR CAN GO THE
NEXT ONE. LINE. EIGHTEEN GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU FOR TAKING MY
CALL. I AM I'M NOT GOING TO GO
OVER EVERYTHING THAT EVERYBODY'S
ALREADY GONE OVER BECAUSE
THEY'RE ALL BRING IN ABSOLUTE
FACT TO THE TABLE IN REGARDS TO
THESE CALLS COMING IN FROM THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT YOU PEOPLE ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE SERVING. IT SEEMS
THAT WHEN PEOPLE HAVE AN OPINION
AS THE REASON THEY ARE
DISCOUNTED AS- YOU DON'T KNOW WE
KNOW BEST IT'S VERY RUDE TO HANG
UP ON SOMEBODY WHEN EVERYBODY'S
TRYING TO DIVIDE- TO COME UP
WITH AN UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT'S
GOING ON THIS IS GOVERNMENT OVER
REACH THROUGH AND THROUGH WE THE
PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT TO SPEAK WE
HAVE A RIGHT TO SAY THAT YOU
GUYS JUST DON'T SEEM TO BE
LISTENING THE FACTS ARE RIGHT
BEFORE YOUR EYES BUT YOU
CONTINUE TO WALK IN AND THIS. IS
MINE YOU'RE NOT SEEING ALL THERE
IS TO SEE YOU WANT TO HOLD ON TO
THIS POWER AND YOU THINK YOU
WANT TO JUST FORGET THE FACT
THAT WE ARE CITIZENS AND WE ARE
THE CONSTITUENTS AND YOU PEOPLE
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE SERVING EVERY
CLIENT TIME I GET ON A PHONE
CALL. THERE IS A MATHEMATICS
GOING. LINE TWENTY FOUR. YES
HELLO- YOU KNOW AS A CONSTITUENT
I SUPPOSE EVERYTHING THAT YOU
ARE PROPOSING ESPECIALLY THE
SMARTER PLAN YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN
OVER TWO YEARS AND WE ARE STILL
IN A STATE OF EMERGENCY THIS IS
NOTHING MORE THAN A POWER GRAB
IN PURE CORRUPTION WHERE IS THE
PROOF TO SUBSTANTIATE MEASURES
CITIZENS HAVE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS THE CONSTITUTION IS THE
LAW OF THE LAND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS FORGOTTEN THAT
THEIR ROLE IS TO PROTECT. THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT OF THE
PRESIDENT WE DON'T NEED ANY ANY
GOVERNMENT WE NEED TO GET OUT OF
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY IT'S TIME
AND YOU'RE GONNA FIND OUT WHEN
EVERYBODY BOTH AT. THE BALLOT
BOX. THANK YOU. NINE NINE. HI
YES I AGREE WITH A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ALREADY AND- I'M
HEARING BACK ART THE THIRD THAT. BUT IS BEGINNING TO- BE
ADVANCED BUT IT'S NOT PEOPLE DO
NOT BUT- THE CONSTITUENCY NOT
BUT BECAUSE OF ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT MANDATE AND- THANKS
EVEN SAYING THAT THERE'S NOT
INFORMATION OR DISINFORMATION.
IT ANOTHER THOUGHT EIGHT OF THE
ISSUE. WHAT WE'RE HEARING IS
ONLY ONE SIDE OF THE ISSUE THIS
IS. THIS IS WHAT SUPPOSED TO BE
OR THIS IS WHAT'S GOING ON BUT
IT'S NOT THERE'S OTHER
INFORMATION OUT THERE THAT THINK
THAT ACT EXACT OPPOSITE NO
ADVOCACY FOR NOW. NO REASON TO
VACCINATE A FIVE YEAR OLD OR A
ONE YEAR OLD I MEAN THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE LITTLE CHILDREN AND
THESE ARE. EXPERIMENTAL THAT
MEANS THAT ARE HARMING OUR
CHILDREN HARMING OUR PEOPLE. AND
I'M ONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT DO GO
TO THE BOARD NINE THE BOARD
MEETINGS AND I TAUGHT BECAUSE-
I'M WORRIED ABOUT MY KIDS. AND
I'M WORRIED ABOUT MY GRANDKIDS.
THESE VACCINE ARE NOT THE ANSWER
. THE ANSWER IS TO HAVE YOU KNOW
THE REMEDY. THAT HELP YOU GET
THROUGH THE COLD AND COLDER
HELLO. THANK YOU. OPPENHEIMER
MORE LINES TO HAVE OPEN. WE HAVE
ONE MORE LINE IN Q. THANK YOU.
THAT IS LINE THIRTY GO HEAD. YES
I'M FINE COMPLEX ACCOUNTING I AM
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
EVERYTHING THAT YOU ALL HAVE BUT
I AM OPPOSED TO THIS. OUR
CHILDREN OUR FUTURE. IT'S THEIR
LIVES AT RISK BUT THIS VACCINE
AND ALL THE OTHER IMPLEMENTED
TRYING TO. APPLY TO THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA PLEASE STOP THIS
IS OVERREACH THIS IS COMMUNISM.-THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND JUST
CONFIRMING OPERATOR THERE NOBODY
ELSE ONLINE. WE DO HAVE ONE MORE
LINE IN Q. ADELINE TWENTY SEVEN. YES GO AHEAD YEAH ONE MINUTE.
ARE WE ARE EVERYTHING I'M
LISTING SHOWS THE GUY AND JUST
IT'S SO ANNOYING TO HEAR CO THE
COCOA THEY'D SHOT SHOT SHOT AND
YOU GUYS PUTTING THE KIDS. UNDER
THE PATERNITY GOING TO THE BUS
OVER THAT THE DISK AS- OP
RIDICULOUS- I HAVE COMPLETELY.
LOST ALL CONFIDENCE IN OUR
GOVERNMENT IN CALIFORNIA AND-
BEYOND THAT- I DO NOT AGREE WITH
THOSE WHATSOEVER A NEED TO STOP
. I HAVEN'T BEEN SIX ONE IN TWO
YEARS AND I DON'T WEAR A MASK
AND I GO OUT ALMOST EVERY DAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU JUST
CONFIRM THAT WAS THE LAST ONE
OPERATOR. THAT'S CORRECT OKAY
WITH THAT WILL GO TO IN PERSON
CONTACT. THIS IS GONNA BE FINE
OKAY THE REASON WHY WE HAVE
THESE EXPERIMENTAL VACCINES IF
YOU DON MASS POLICIES AND LESS
TESTING IS BECAUSE WE WERE LED
TO BELIEVE THERE WAS NO CURE FOR
SARS THE A B. TWO. SOME SAY A
BIO WEAPON THAT'S SIMPLY UNTRUE
ONE EFFECTIVE AND INEXPENSIVE
TREATMENT AS A HYDROXYL OR CREAM
PROTOCOL ANOTHER ONE IS
IVERMECTIN WHICH MIGHT BE EVEN
SAFER BECAUSE THERE'S NO
ANTIBIOTICS THESE ARE FACTS NOT
FAKE NEWS NOR CONSPIRACY
THEORIES YOU CAN CONTINUE TO
CANCEL CENTER DISMISSED THE
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS. LIKE
AMERICA'S FRONTLINE DOCTORS HAVE
BEEN POURING US TO LISTEN TO
THEIR NUMEROUS SUCCESS STORIES
BUT THAT'LL NEVER CHANGE THE
TRUTH AND WHY WOULD THEY BE
CENSORED WHY ARE PEOPLE ASKING
THESE QUESTIONS THE TRUTH IS
EVEN TWO YEARS LATER OUR FIRST
WORLD HOSPITALS CONTINUE TO KILL
OUR CITIZENS WITH BLATANT
MEDICAL NEGLECT BY NOT PROVIDING
ANY TREATMENT AT THE ONSET OF
SYMPTOMS. LEADING TO
ADMINISTERING DEADLY BUT
DISAPPEAR AND THE VENTILATOR
DEATH SENTENCE MY LITTLE SISTER
SPENT THE ENTIRE MONTH OF
JANUARY IN THE HOSPITAL SO
FIRSTHAND I THOUGHT. DO I IT AT
LAND THIS IS. TERRORISM AND ALL
INVOLVED OR COMPLICIT IN CRIMES
AGAINST HUMANITY FOR ACTUALLY
SINCERE IN THE SAVING LIVES
NARRATIVE HOW ABOUT WE STARTED
HEARING TO THE HIPPOCRATIC OATH
OF DOING NO HARM. LET THE
DOCTORS TREAT THEIR PATIENTS THE
WAY THEY SEE FIT WITHOUT. FEAR
OF PENELAS ATION AND PROVIDING
TRUE INFORMED CONSENT WHERE WE
TELL YOU THE SIDE EFFECTS BEFORE
WE INJECT YOU WITH SOMETHING.
AND MAYBE PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO
VACCINATE THEIR CHILDREN BECAUSE
THEY SAW ENOUGH TEENAGERS DROP
DEAD WITH MYOCARDITIS. AND THEY
KNOW THAT THEIR CHILDREN WILL
SURVIVE THE VIRUS. BUT THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO SURVIVE THE ADVERSE
EVENTS IN THIS. IT'S RIDICULOUS
THIS IS ALL AVAILABLE THIS
INFORMATION THAT'S CALLED THIS
INFORMATION IS BEING HIDDEN IT'S
NOT. IT'S NOT A LIE AND IT'S
JUST OKAY MEMBER MADE RUNS ONE
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU FOR THAT MAY I SPEAK I JUST
WANNA SAY WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO
THIS WHOLE PANDEMIC IT REALLY
COMES DOWN THE GOVERNMENT OVER
REACH WHEN IT COMES TO THE
MANDATES. FOR TWO YEARS GAVIN
NEWSOM HOW TO SAVE EMERGENCY HE
CLAIMED AT TWELVE TWENTY FIVE
AND A HALF MILLION CALIFORNIANS
WILL BE AFFECTED RECOVERY WHEN
IN REALITY WE HAVEN'T REACHED
THAT AT ALL AND SO IT ALL COMES
DOWN TO JUST THE MANDATE HI
EVERYBODY HAS BEEN NO YOU GOT TO
DO THIS YOU CAN GET JOBLESS YOU
THE VACCINE AND THAT'S BEEN A
PROBLEM SO NOW MORE PEOPLE
ACTUALLY WORKING FROM HOME.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T GO TO THE JOB
AND GET THE VACCINES SO WE JUST
WANT YOU GUYS TO UNDERSTAND THAT
IT'S YOU GUYS WHO DO WORK FOR US
WE THE PEOPLE A I HOPE THAT WE
CAN FIND SOME COMMON GROUND ON
THAT THAT'S THE WHOLE PROBLEM
BEGIN BELIEE WHICH WANT TO
VACCINE WE GET THEM BACK TO GET
THE VACCINE WHEN WERE MASS WERE
AMASSEDBUT DON'T TELL PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE TO DO THIS OTHERWISE
THEY CAN'T DO THAT AND THAT'S
NOT RIGHT SURE THE BUSINESSES
HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO IT IN THE
PRIVATE COMPANY DO WHAT THEY
WANT BY THE STATE TIMES STAFF ON
THE BALLOT TO WHERE WE COULD NOT
BE TELLING PEOPLE WHAT TO DO.
SIMPLY BECAUSE YOU GUYS ARE IN
CHARGE OF THE PEOPLE THE ONES
THAT ELECTED YOU- THE BIG LEAD
LIKE SHE THAT THE ONLY WAY THE
INFORMATION IS OUT THERE EVERY
OUT OF THE DOCKED PAL SHE
ADMITTED THAT ARE DYING BUT HE
SAYS BECAUSE OF THE ONE BUT IT'S
STILL A IF I PEOPLE AT THE WHEN
THEY GOT THIS. SO IT'S ALL ABOUT
GOV OVER OF NEED NOT THAT
ANYMORE JUST ALLOW FOLKS TO DO
WHAT'S BEST FOR THEM WITHOUT A
BE A MANDATED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE NEXT. YES SO FROM.
I'D LIKE TO TELL YOU- TWO
STORIES OF HARM NOT FROM COVERT
BECAUSE FORTUNATELY COVERT FOR
MOST AS A COLDER A BAD FLU. BUT
HARM FROM. THE POLICIES SET
FORTH IN CALIFORNIA. SO MY
HUSBAND WORKS IN A HOSPITAL HE
HAD TO GET THREE JOBS. ON THE
THIRD ONE HE HAD AN ADVERSE
REACTION HE HAS ATTENDED THIS
FROM IT TO THIS DAY. IT'S NOT
GOING AWAY IT'S PROBABLY
PERMANENT. AND NO ONE'S TALKING
ABOUT VACCINE INJURY THERE'S AN
- EVER OKAY KIDS ARE AFFECTED BY
IT TOO THEY CAN GET MYOCARDITIS
FOR THAT REASON AS WELL AS OTHER
CONDITIONS AND FOR THAT REASON
MY SON. DID NOT WANT TO GET THE
JOB AND NOW HE'S FACING SERIOUS
DISCRIMINATION NOT. AND THIS IS
ALL BECAUSE OF A CALIFORNIA'S
POLICIES YOU WOULD LIKE TO GO TO
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR UC OR OF
CSU. BUT TO GO IN PERSON THEY
REQUIRE. THE CALL THE JOB.
UNLESS HE GETS A RELIGIOUS
EXEMPTION WHICH IS NOT
GUARANTEED BY ANY MEANS. SO WE
NEED TO DO TWO THINGS STOP ALL
MANDATES LOOK INTO VACCINE
INJURY IT'S REAL AND THIRDLY.
THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE VACCINE
INJURED THEY DON'T GET ANY
COMPENSATION BECAUSE THE VACCINE
MAKERS HAVE LEGAL IMMUNITY. OKAY
SO WHATEVER INJURY THEY SUFFERED
THERE'S NOWHERE FOR THEM TO TURN
. OKAY SO- PLEASE DO YOU LOOK AT
THE SCIENCE OKAY. LOOK AT LAKE
DATA FROM ISRAEL THAT SHOWS
YOUNG ADULTS HAVE INCREASED
RATES OF CARDIAC ARREST AFTER
VACCINATION THIS IS NINETEEN TO
FORTY YEAR OLD THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY ELEVATED THEY DID
THE STUDIES- YOU KNOW LOOK AT.
LOOK AT THE WALL GREEN STATE IT
SHOWS THAT VACCINATED TEST
POSITIVE MORE FREQUENTLY FOR
COVER THAN THE UNVACCINATED.
DATA FROM ENGLAND SERVES
CHILDREN WHO WERE VACCINATED ARE
DYING AT A MUCH HIGHER RATE
OVERALL THIS IS SO SIGNIFICANT
OKAY LIKE MY SON HE'S SKINNY
HE'S HEALTHY HE HAS NO CO
MORBIDITIES HE HAS HE'S LREADY
HAD COVERT HE HAS ZERO REASON TO
GET VACCINATED. BECAUSE IT'S ALL
DOWNSIDE AND NO PLUS SIDE SO WHY
WHY WOULD ANY YOU SEE YOUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE MAKE HIM GET
VACCINATED THIS IS CRIMINAL.
PLEASE RECONSIDER WHAT YOU'RE
DOING THANK YOU THANK YOU-
ANYONE ELSE. HELLO EVERYBODY MY
NAME'S CHURCH CASTING YEAH THIS
IS MY FIRST TIME HERE I KNOW YOU
SAID ONE MINUTE I REPRESENT SEIU
LOCAL ONE THOUSAND AND ALL THE
STATE WORKERS THAT'S A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE SO I'M ASKING
CAN I PLEASE HAVE MORE THAN ONE
MINUTE. THIS IS A CRIMINAL TWO
MINUTES THANK YOU NOW THIS IS A
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY THAT YOU GUYS
ARE NOT AWARE OF OKAY THOMAS.
I'VE SENT HIM TO PUBLIC RECORD
REQUESTS AND ALSO TO DEMANDS TO
MEET AND CONFER HE'S IGNORED ME
HE SIGNED A CONTRACT IN AUGUST
OF TWENTY TWENTY. WITH COLOR
GENOMICS INC COLOR GENOMICS INC
IS A COVERT TESTING LAB WAS NO
BID ON THIS CONTRACT IT DIDN'T
GO TO DGS LIKE IT SHOULD HAVE WE
SENT HIM A CEASE AND DESIST WE
MET WITH THEM WE DIDN'T SETTLE
OUR CASE UNTIL SEPTEMBER TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ALREADY SIGNED THE
COLOR CONTRACT. GUARANTEEING
THAT STATE WORKERS HAD TO COMPLY
WITH GIVING UP THEIR PERSONAL
IDENTIFICATION INFORMATION P. I.
N. BIOLOGICAL SPECIMEN MEANING
OUR DNA OKAY AND WE DO NOT HAVE
AN OPTION TO OPT OUT IF WE DO
NOT CONSENT TO THIS CONTRACT WE
WILL BE TERMINATED I WAS
TERMINATED THERE'S HARM DONE I
WAS A FIFTEEN YEAR STATE
EMPLOYEES. DISMISSED AFTER. I
COULD NOT CONSENT TO THAT FORM
IT IS CALLED EXTORTION PENAL
CODE FIVE EIGHTEEN THOMAS ARAGON
WILL BE SUBPOENAED AT MY HEARING
BECAUSE HE IS DOING CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY HE IS COLLUDING WITH
GAVIN NEWSOM. TO EXTORT THE DNA
OF OUR CHILDREN TRYING TO GET
COLOR GENOMICS INC IN THE
SCHOOLS WE ALLOW THAT THIS
COMPANY CLEARLY STATES THAT THEY
USE THE GENETIC INFORMATION FOR
MARKETING AND RESEARCH PURPOSES
WHAT KIND OF RESEARCH WELL COLOR
RECEIVED FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
FROM NIH FOR THE GUARANTEED
RETURN GENOMIC DATA. DNA
INFORMATION BIOTERRORIST WEAPONS
CAN BE BUILT FROM THAT RIGHT WE
DON'T KNOW MAYBE THEY'RE DOING
CANCER RESEARCH WE CAN HOPE BUT
IF THEY'RE LYING TO US IN THEIR
CHEATING US. LIKELY THAT THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO DO GOOD THINGS WITH
THE INFORMATION AND FOR US TO
HAVE TO BE FORCED INTO GIVING
OUR CONSENT THAT'S EXTORTION I
DID NOT CONSENT SO I CAN'T SEE
THE EXTORTED DATA FROM ME BUT
THEY DID FROM MY COWORKERS AND I
AM A UNION STEWARD IT WOULD MY-
JOB TO REP. THEM I WAS
TERMINATED TELLING MY DIRECTOR
STEVE GORDON WHAT WAS GOING ON.
YOU KNOW WHY BECAUSE HE'S
COLLUDING WITH NEW SOME TO I SK
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU DO NOT
CONTINUE TO COLLUDE WITH THE
ENEMY THEY ARE COMMITTING
TREASON AGAINST US. WARNINGS WE
ARE NOT THERE EQUITY HISPANIC
PEOPLE DO NOT WANT TO BE
TARGETED. THE REASON WE ARE
SAYING SO YOUR TIME'S UP. NO IS
IT CAUSES ADVERSE REACTION. HEY
WE'RE NOT. WITHOUT GOD THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU
EVERYONE PARTICIPATING.